Okay.
Yeah.
Good experience.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I never knew.
I never do.
Sorry.
I don't hear anything Brian.
You don't hear anything?
Oh yeah,
my self at all.
Hello?
Do we have technical issues?
I don't hear myself either.
Yeah,
I hear you guys.
we hear you,
dude.
We hear you.
But we don't hear ourselves.
You just did something.
You turning it out.
Hello?
What'd you just do?
Stan.
Oh,
not too.
Why?
Look at that first cause no one uses it.
She plays with that,
right dude,
the cats.
The cats get in here and start whacking shit around.
Yeah.
Tell me when it's good.
They don't like it when we kick them out.
I can't hear me at all.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you.
You're probably using the wrong headphones.
Is there another period?
What am I talking to that man talking about?
Can you hear me right now?
Not very well.
Try it again right now.
Right now.
Hello?
Yeah,
I can't,
I can't really hear.
I can hear me a little bit,
which is right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now I hear,
yeah.
Oh my God.
It extracts the,
yeah,
I think we were supposed to be on this one.
We don't know what the fuck we're doing or a new desk and I'm very excited,
but I'm also very excited per Chrysler was in the motherfucking house.
Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for Bert.
Kreischer the first like real fan of the show to come on the show.
Um,
I can't,
I don't know.
Sort of know,
you know,
because I listened to,
I listened to every single one.
Oh,
well thanks man.
That's awesome.
That's the best way people,
anyone I saw on a chat board,
someone's like,
there's,
you'll only be an hour.
I couldn't use them for four hours while some people like it if it's only an
hour,
but then just listen to an hour.
If I shut it off,
I like the long flight.
I'm flying to Miami,
I'm going to pass out in the middle and have to rewind them.
Figure out how the fuck a monkey can hold.
How does everyone on the show so fucking smart.
I never thought Ralphie was that smart.
Like just hanging out with them.
You know,
if you've got to put up that kind of that much material.
We,
Ralphie May's got hours and hours.
His Shit.
You know a guy like that.
You gotta be intelligent.
You got to be intelligent to be a comic.
Yeah.
Some people are smart as shit.
What is going on with the sound,
Brian?
Echoing.
It's really loud.
Yeah.
Hello.
I need to be closer.
This,
this is all very different than yesterday.
We're crusher.
He's a fucking robot.
Yeah.
His voice doesn't work like normal human voices.
Huh?
We good now?
I think so.
Okay.
Maybe were stoned.
Yeah,
that's definitely the case.
It's the vaporizer gives you a different hospital,
different,
little more intense going vaporizer lately ladies and gentlemen,
cutting out the middle man,
concentrate to the THC.
Um,
you know,
the,
the conversations we have,
that's one of the most fun things about it.
I mean,
we always have these conversations like,
especially Dunkin and I,
we,
we would have hours and hours of super bake conversation.
Brian Count Too.
I fell in love with Dunkin and saw him on a plane and went back to where he was
sitting and could not stop talking to him about getting back into weed.
Oh really?
Really trying to get back into weed.
It's just,
I don't,
it's not like you're trying to take yoga.
My wife and my sisters had an intervention and they were like this and you're
drinking way too much.
And I was like,
okay.
And they're like,
we got you a bag of Afghany Kush,
like start there.
And then I did and I got rookie bait like that happened to me once.
I got really scared ones because uh,
I'd,
I'd gotten upset at myself for like making fun of Steven Seagal.
Is this,
how high was,
I was so happy.
I called Eddie Bravo.
Okay.
I was super baked,
paranoid and I'm like,
what am I going fight Stevens to golf?
I see him like,
I don't even really care about it.
I'm like,
why am I speaking so mean when I'm making fun of them?
Cause I was making fun of him,
just,
we were relentlessly and brutally.
And I thought about it while Super Beta was like,
what if I met that guy?
Two things.
First of all,
I'd probably would be nice to him,
which is like the most hypocritical shit ever worse.
And second of all,
I would probably feel terrible for like being so mean and making bad jokes.
Fleshlight yeah.
Which box is so bad.
This is,
this is the alien one.
you haven't come in.
No,
no one has.
No one has,
I know that.
That's a joke.
He liked to play all friends.
That's Brian.
He doesn't,
he doesn't run these flashlights.
These are in my possession.
It's pretty awesome.
It's really good for shooting loads into,
oh my God.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net and you click the link,
you put in a Rogan,
you get 15% off the podcast or off the,
uh,
the flashlight.
Here's how you clean it.
Have you seen this part?
Unscrew the bottom and just dump it out and pick the top and,
but the faucet on the top right through,
that's it.
I'm going to leave it in,
just leave the loads and the tenement magnet nom wow.
Having like a real moment with my fleshlight conversation with their long day
really long.
Speaking of Vietnam,
I saw a really interesting documentary or a piece rather.
It was a very short clip about a,
they were talking about how marijuana it was changed war and how Vietnam was the
first war where the soldiers were smoking marijuana and they became reluctant to
fight and it was all about the mentality of the soldiers just completely changed
when they're in Southeast Asia and they were smoking weed and they could smell
the Viet cong smoking weed like over the hill.
Like they were like close enough to each other's smell each other's we'd shut
up.
And one guy was talking about how there was one time where he was high and he
had seen this Vietnamese,
uh,
this Viet Cong soldier and he knew that that guy was high too.
It's like they looked at each other and they knew they were high.
He just started when they knew that I didn't even know each other and I'm going
to shoot each other because you know,
some fucking people in an office somewhere say that this is how it's supposed to
go down.
But those Vietnam guys were the first generation to hear stories about war.
Yeah.
Cause their dads came back.
My great grandfather came back from World War One world war two and was fucked
up like fucked up.
Like,
and they didn't know that you could fix it.
They just thought,
well that's what happened to my life.
I was 18 and it just switched and I'll drink beer in the garage by myself.
Well they don't know what to fix it with.
Even though what they're doing now,
they're,
they're really taking the long way around.
What they really should be doing is given,
given the soldiers,
the ones you know,
that want to do something about post traumatic stress disorder,
me shouldn't impose it on them,
but giving them Ibogaine.
I begin and,
um,
Iowasca are two of the most potent psychedelic mixtures and they're responsible
for so many different people getting off of heroin,
getting overly fast.
Yes.
That students like conversations with God,
that would be like the worst thing possible.
That gives somebody never touch with reality.
You know,
know what it does is it lets them know what really happened.
It lets them see it from an emotional perspective why there's this big gigantic
hole in them that that freaks out whenever they think about the past and freaks
out and re relives all these moments.
And you can go over it with WWE,
especially with Ibogaine.
I've heard so many different stories about,
and also with the Mtma,
you know,
MDA,
which is accuracy using therapy with that,
that was the idol on its drug when you didn't know what the fuck you up.
Well it does fuck you up though.
That's why I won't do it.
I did it once and that was it for me and,
but I learned a lot,
man.
I,
I learned a lot about like insecurities and,
but anyway,
the point is about,
about soldiers like you know,
and people that are addicted,
there's people that have like problems with heroin,
problems with alcohol.
They can fix all that shit with Ibogaine.
But Geraldo,
I said like when in one of his lowest points took a bunch of acid cause he said
that he heard that that would fix his problems and he said it didn't,
we'll acids not known for that.
I mean acid.
Well it is kind of self,
right?
Yeah.
But I think acid also just freaks people out so much at Mike when it wears out
you off,
it's like,
so
someone described it as abrasively introspective that just like so freaked you
out that it might be too much for someone who has like an addiction.
Now Mushrooms,
I think our lunchrooms are good.
Anything that's enlightening,
anything that allows you to step back and look at.
But it has to also jive with your biochemistry.
You can say everything enlightening.
But what if you're the one weirdo that's allergic to peanuts and you know he
can't even drink diet coke or you get splitting headaches.
Are there people that are allergic to we'd like physicians are,
there must be people that are allergic to everything.
I would think a lot of bronc like people that have like smoking allergies in
general unit.
They,
yeah,
but if that's the case or the allergic to have to the Eden there,
uh,
what about vaporizing?
It still has smoking and I don't care what it's missing.
Yeah,
that's the whole deal.
You still cough from it?
I don't call from it.
I my hop yesterday,
he coughed yesterday from it cause I remember going,
ah,
you're going to be relief.
Fuck now.
No,
I think think so.
Brian,
I think you're attaching that moment,
that memory to some other time.
I didn't really Demitri Martin is allergic to alcohol.
Rarely.
Yeah.
And peanuts.
Like if you thought I shouldn't say that,
that could be really mean and
throw something else in there if to
allergic to pussy.
Stupid.
I don't even know the dude.
Then if there was an opening right there.
He's a his he,
yeah,
and he is allergic to alcohol.
So what happens when you drink?
Oh,
he breaks out.
If you throw a peanut on his face,
his face will swell up.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Talk about fucking being helpless on stage.
Someone doesn't like your throat showing just flicks a peanut allergy.
Does he know?
He knows people but now people know now people,
I just fucked him,
mocked him out man.
People going to be throwing peanuts at them.
That's just kind of fucked up because I've worked in summit so many kitchens
before where like easily there could be peanut in something and then just be
dumb waitress that didn't know or you're at the,
you're making a salad and a peanut flies into something and it just seems like
ties like pad Thai peanut sauce and shit.
Lady in front of me was allergic to shellfish on the fight yesterday coming back
from DC and they gave her a shrimp and put it in front of her and she flipped
out.
She was like,
I can't have it around me.
I can't,
I can't even be around it like and I was like,
oh that's if we have the land of fucking pain.
Cause there's chick canny felt shellfish.
Whoa.
She was freaking out.
She was freaking me out.
Pretty bad people do though.
Cause that's her.
Think about that.
That's your windpipe like I'm allergic to durables.
Right,
right.
And people wouldn't recognize it and I had fucking bash your swell up and stuff.
My wife,
my kids got at her school,
they got a durable and so my wife was playing with the durable one morning and
then washed her hands,
got in the car,
grabbed the steering wheel.
I went to take my sister to the airport,
My eyes shut.
This,
this part,
you know this part of your eye,
that lining part swole up over my eyes.
Oh,
I'm okay.
I started co water's coming out of my eyes and it's burning lines down my face.
My windpipe closes up and I'm just like,
I don't know what's happening at the time cause I'm like,
I just fucking Santa car.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
this is a stroke.
Something's going down.
I call my wife and then I started thinking,
did she fucking play with the Jerboa?
I just asked out of the blue.
She was like,
but I washed my hands and I was like,
fucking wow.
Can you believe that?
That's what I rely on my hands now.
Right.
You fuck you did.
Was your last your fucking hands trying to make up for it?
Revision is history of Motherfucker,
but yeah,
but I washed my,
yeah.
Well that's one of the nonsense.
Craziness.
It sounds like something with a 13 year old would tell you.
So could you walk through like a pet store if you just didn't touch anything or
have you ever done that just because you're feeling dangerous on a Saturday?
Fuck No.
So crazy.
So anybody that has a durable in their hand and touch the door Knob,
you can touch that.
And which is Jackie?
Oh,
if I thought like I'm allergic to cats,
but I live with my,
my wife has a cat so I live with it.
So I've gotten over the allergy.
Wow.
That must've been crazy in the beginning of the relationship.
Huh?
Fucking talk about swallowing your pride and fucking deciding and my life is
more less important.
Dating this chick.
Wow.
And the doctor,
we sat down with an hour,
it's just one time.
And he's like,
so here's the deal.
The cat cannot be in the room with him.
Or One night he might die and then you and the cat is fucking there.
Any website.
But I love the cat.
She tried,
she tried,
but she hear the cat
clawing under the door and she wanted to let them in.
Let them see she's done the cat longer than me.
I'm like,
four months in,
Oh fuck.
It was all sold.
Destructive.
You got chose over killed.
I'm going to have to kill that cow,
dude.
The cat,
she called one night,
she,
when we were moving apartment,
she was like,
we can't find Gus Gus.
And I was like,
it's too bad.
I was like,
sweet.
And then I came home for like a day,
we couldn't find this cat.
Right.
And then my daughters are getting upset because they're like,
Daddy,
Gus,
Gus is,
he's hungry.
I'm like,
he's a fucking street.
Caddy can fend for himself.
So then I go into the older old apartment to look for him and I hear him,
he's in the fucking dryer.
Oh you turned in front of me is like there's a moment where you have to make the
call.
Do I just not say anything and just leave like in that then those fucking movies
where you just go,
ah,
and just walk by or do I rescue the cat and deal with my allergies?
And I'm like,
I'm can't fucking kill an animal.
I can't let an animal die on my watch.
Not like daddy not to kill it.
We stop on its head,
punched it or kill it.
Kill my cat.
When I was in my phone,
when I was in high school,
my dad accidentally threw the cat and the dryer.
Yeah.
I didn't know the cat had gone to sleep in the hammock or in the,
in the um,
the hamper.
Cause it was a warm clothes in the hamper.
And um,
no,
no.
That's not the of the story.
The story was there was,
I guess he went to sleep in the dryer,
whatever.
Somehow or another the cat got in the fucking dryer by accident and my dad
hurdle is thump,
thump,
thump.
And he opened it once and looked in.
The cat was out and the cat didn't move,
so it was like,
well,
why don't we just,
nothing's in here.
And so he shouted again and again from the dump dump,
dump,
dump.
And they had to like a couple of minutes to this man.
Then he opens it up and the cat comes out,
screech in and one of his teeth was broken off and my,
my father felt so bad.
He felt awful.
It was just a such a bad scene.
You know the cat lived though.
That's a shitty story.
Cat lived with one fucked up tooth.
He says one fucked up tooth that reminded you of like no one did.
This cat's crazy.
Imagine one day you wake up and your blackness and you're falling on metal every
half a second,
you just get beat over the head.
If someone's beating the fuck out of you and you're flipping through the air,
what a crazy way to wake up inside a dry and then to survive that after minutes
and minutes and then fucking drive.
My buddy who passed out and fell into a pool and that was a terrifying way to
wake up.
He did Ibogaine the cat needs.
I'm just going to say,
why don't you heal that cannabis and psychedelics,
Hilda countless,
some ecstasy by the way,
don't,
don't listen to anything I say.
Don't take anything I tell you to take.
Stop it.
Don't,
don't listen.
I am just a fucking comedian.
All right?
I am not qualified to be diagnosing life changing chemicals to any fucking
freaks.
A lot of those guys that come back like my cousin,
they're fucking fearless from the war.
You can't fuck.
You can't phase these dudes like,
yeah.
Once you've watched a bunch of people shoot at you and you shoot it and kill
people and then you got some fucking frat boy telling you he's going to knock
your teeth in at a bar and you watch my
cousin not give a shit.
Literally just go really,
like he got wasted this weekend and fell down a flight of stairs and split his
head open.
And he was like,
and all his buddies are like,
he's fine.
I'm like,
dude,
he has a head injury.
He fell down fucking that.
The DCM prob down those stairs.
I never been to DC and proud.
It's like a fucking slippery icy stares.
Wow.
And so he and they were like,
he's fine.
He's fine.
They'll call fucking ambulance.
Just Johnny,
you gotta be fine.
Johnny going to be fine.
He's,
and he,
and then he starts throwing up cause he's a concussion all over the place.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
we're calling an ambulance.
I don't give a shit,
but they're fucking,
you just can't feed these kids,
man.
That's a new generation coming back here.
Toughen it up.
Yeah.
Now coming back here after those experiences,
hundreds of thousands of them.
Right.
God,
Oh,
stand up to that change.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
so unfortunate.
You know,
it's so unfortunate that you got people that are willing to do,
you know,
literally anything for their country like Pat Tillman type people who really are
true heroes.
And then,
you know,
you look at what they get used for,
you look at how chaotic you talked to any soldier that comes back from
Afghanistan and tell you it's fucking chaos over there.
No one thinks you could fix that place.
That place is bananas.
That's fucked.
So fucking war lords,
man.
It's like Michael Vick's dogs again,
just kind of fucking crazy and there that,
another thing is they fuck boys over there like on a regular basis.
It's like there's all the weird culture over there where they,
there's a lot of like men who taken like little young boys,
like they fucked them like on a regular basis.
It's like a natural part of their culture.
It's so common and so prevalent.
Like everything over there is so alien to us.
There's like one city in the whole country and the rest of the country.
It's just like warlords.
It's like,
do you can't control it.
There's like a hundred different fucking dudes with a hundred different,
you know,
harems and you know,
they're,
they're rocking one part of the country and holding it down and they need to
know the best way they get information from the students,
the way they communicate with these dudes.
They give him Viagra.
That's what the American soldiers do.
Viagara cause they can't fuck their wives anymore.
So it's hard to hold this Harem.
It's hard to be a warlord when you,
Dick doesn't work anymore.
So they're given him Viagra and now he's like 60 year old dudes who were just
trying to hang on and keep the young bucks at bay.
Now they can bone again so they can get some credibility.
You can't have love it.
18 hot young wives and not fuck any of them.
Someone's going to fuck one of those bitches.
You know it's going to happen.
You're going to have to shoot some young males or something.
You're gonna have to prove your dominance.
Wouldn't you have,
if you had gotten fucked in the ass as a child,
wouldn't you say I'm in his way?
I am.
I'd be like,
well,
I didn't enjoy that,
so I'm not going to do it to somebody else.
Well,
that's an a rat,
rational,
logical way of thinking and,
but apparently what happens to some people's minds when something traumatic
happens to them as their mind gets rewired in a very,
very unhealthy way.
And somehow or another when people are molested,
they have,
uh,
some folks have a,
an urge to do the exact same thing that happened to them,
to someone else.
Almost like they're reliving their pain and their tragedy and reintroducing it
to another person to try to understand it or something.
I mean,
it's like,
it becomes an addiction to them.
This,
it becomes very,
very sick.
Women sometimes get raped a state day raped.
Try to fuck the same guy over again to try to like make sure it was okay.
Wow.
And then a lot of times those guys don't want to be in that situation again
because I know they did the bad thing.
So then they veer away from it and then that fucking ruins the woman that got
date raped.
Oh God.
That's horrible,
man.
I hate psycho psychological shit.
The way your brain tries to fix things is insane.
It isn't.
I think that's why.
That's why I glean is so dangerous.
You know when you hear about the kids at school to get stuffed in a locker and
all those and then wind up committing suicide and some kid recently,
um,
fuck this store was so crazy,
some,
I don't know the full details of it.
It was someone something someone would toman but at some 14 year old kid,
there was a bunch of kids,
they were out on some little event.
This kid climbs to the top of a 10 stories,
breaks a window and jumps out in front of everybody.
So they're all on there on some fucking vacation or some school trip or some
shit.
This kid's smashes a window and just sky dives into the pavement in front of the
whole class.
No bullied at all.
Nia,
I was bullied.
Yeah,
that's how I got into martial arts.
Really?
Yeah.
I think almost every comedian is bullied with me.
I,
I moved.
I was,
first of all,
I was a little,
I wasn't a big guy and I moved around a lot when my family was seven.
We moved from New Jersey to Florida or New Jersey to California and then
California to Florida.
So it's like I never really like stayed long enough to make like good friends.
I would like live in one place.
And even California we lived in one street and the next year we lived,
you know,
a half away across town.
And then,
you know,
in Florida we moved a couple of times.
It's like,
man,
I just never really had a chance to make like long lasting friends.
I went to an all boys Catholic high school.
Oh Geez.
That was just torture meet.
And then I was like the funny,
like the funny guy in my friends.
So the older dudes are just fuck you up.
And that wasn't even like bullying just beat me up.
Wow.
This is like,
you just got,
you knew he got beaten up one time.
This,
this guy on the baseball team,
uh,
Friday result,
I'll say his name.
Like your shit that day.
He's still a beast.
He was a beast when we were all fucking like children.
He was the head like ball hair,
like he was a monster to him and he sends a little kid with a beard.
Do the guy was shaving in like eighth grade.
I mean he was a monster in his arms were huge.
And he was a captain of our baseball team and I was like probably junior or
sophomore and he,
I was making a joke and he said,
Greg Sher shut your face.
So I like as a joke and that he did not get that.
And then he went to go fight me and then I was like,
but then they broke it up.
Wow.
So then we get done,
he goes into the dugout and I'm playing catch with my buddies,
Joe and Troy Dean and warming up and we see them walking out and we're walking
in there like,
oh,
Freddy gets upset sometimes,
but he's just coming to apologize.
You look,
he's got a bandage,
probably had enough to the bio and batting practice and he's just going to say
sorry.
So it was like,
okay,
don't worry.
I got this one.
So I have a glove in hand ball on the other hand I'm like,
Hey Freddie.
And then he just with the baseball batches,
beat the shit out of me.
My friends got all of them.
They couldn't pull this guy off of me and never let go of the ball and then,
you know,
and then of course I just go to crying cause I was still like a young boy and
then,
and then he beat me up and then the coach was
in there and sudden and fucking,
and then we both played left field together.
So I had to go out and sit in left field with them after that.
But those things like that's why I think women's,
that's patty.
You,
how do you get past that moment and when run by him again when this guy beat the
shit out of here.
He came to see me at the Tampa Improv recently and he,
he,
me and him probably never talked about it.
We were cool after that.
Like,
I mean we were like,
you know,
we put it on the same team for a year after that.
And,
but he came to the camp and probably he's like,
what's up man?
I was like,
hey,
how you doing?
And then,
but I'm still like gun shy,
you know,
cow head.
The guy in Tampa radio show cow head.
I used to tell a story about getting in a fight with a black guy.
There was a,
I did all my hour special and it's a real story.
It's a true story about getting the shit kicked out of my [inaudible] Buckeye.
Cal had looked him up and found the dude and was like,
I'm bringing them in studio.
Oh my God.
I was like,
please don't fucking do that.
I was praying the guy was dead and be his daughter,
listens to the show or whatever.
I was like fuck.
Cause I'm telling jokes about this guy on stage for the past eight years,
there was this one dude that I went to high school with.
I don't even remember his name.
I think it was Kevin.
He was this black kid that was way bigger than everybody else who's like this
football player.
I didn't really know him very well.
I knew his brother,
his brother was a nice guy,
but he was a scary dude to me.
It just looked like look,
a Mike Tyson looking dude.
Yeah.
And you know,
I remember like no one ever fucked with this kid and everybody was always
nervous,
but there was something about them where I'd be like,
man,
this guy just seems like he just seems like too dangerous.
Like there's something about him,
like that makes me fucking nervous.
Like someone could be that much bigger than you when you're 16 years old that
much.
It turns out he bought up murdering somebody.
Oh yeah.
We have one kid or our neighborhood.
Uh,
definitely won't say this guy's fucking name.
Um,
the one kid you knew was weird but you didn't know like how to,
like,
you just,
everyone would be like,
who wants to go ride bikes?
And he's like,
who dares me to go in the woods and put a stick in my ass?
Like that kind of kid.
Just crazy.
One night he was,
he had the keys to his,
this chick that lives in our neighborhood.
He had accused her house because his parents were watching their house and he's
like,
hey,
you want to go in her house and get weird?
And I was like,
they're not here.
He's like,
no,
come on and be fucking crazy.
I go in there and cut the SPA pussies out of their underwear.
And I was like,
oh.
So my sister calls me like,
like six months ago.
She's like,
uh,
you remember?
Uh,
John?
And I was like,
yeah.
She was like,
he's in jail.
I go,
really?
She goes,
yeah.
He was working for,
um,
for circuit city when they're going out of business and he stole one of their
trucks,
filled with a bunch of equipment.
And I was like,
really?
And she goes,
yeah.
And they arrested him and then they fingerprinted him and found out he had been
killing checks down by the causeway.
Wow.
I was like,
cereal,
if you fucking said serial killer to me,
I would've been like,
if I was the guy next door,
I'd be like,
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I saw that comment.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
How many girls did he kill?
I've no idea,
but,
but I was like,
and I've looked for it online,
online,
I can't find it online.
It's so hard when you run into someone who's completely fucking crazy.
It's like,
what,
you know,
there's no way to fix that guy when you're 15,
16 years old or whatever and you're all of a,
you're going to high school
and you're hanging out with this kid who you know is completely insane and it's
a small neighborhood,
like eight boys.
That's it.
Oh my God.
And we spend the night at this kid's house and like,
just fuck I,
and I'm like,
Holy Shit,
man.
He,
I'm going under.
When he started,
you've got to,
you've got to be,
it starts young.
I remember him shooting a frog with a BB gun and I remember him asking me to do
it and I couldn't do it.
I couldn't kill an animal.
I just couldn't in my head,
you know,
at that age.
But he was like,
it's fun.
It's easy,
it's easy,
they don't move.
But,
uh,
I think you have to start.
It's got to start in college.
I wonder what it is.
You know,
because some people like Jeffrey Dahmer,
they say there's nothing wrong with his upbringing.
You know,
some people were abused when they were younger.
Some people have some,
you know,
various reasons for why they're so fucking crazy and psychotic.
But with dom or Tom or was one of those weird ones where they like,
there's nothing's wrong with his childhood,
but what parent's going to be like,
yeah,
I did that.
Right,
right.
Of course.
Dahmer's parents aren't be like,
fucking didn't know.
You're not supposed to finger they're assholes.
Right.
By the way,
speaking to figure their asshole.
I saw a clip online of your show where you went to the Gracie Academy in
Torrance and a,
you're talking about defense and he said,
well,
I'll just grab their balls and figured their ass all at Horry and just stone
faced you and the way you held it,
dude was so funny.
I was laughing out loud.
You held it just staring at him for like fucking 10 seconds,
man,
where it wasn't like no one said anything.
And then he's like,
okay,
let's go.
Loads of techniques.
Some arm locks in some joint locks in some chokes.
Dude,
I got choked out that Dan has that isn't that fucked me up for like a week cause
you know what it's like to to die.
You know what it's like to be totally helpless and your wind pipe to close and
your blood to stop and you fight it just like you've seen the movies where you
go.
No,
no,
no.
Very helpless.
Especially with the g on man.
When guys get color chokes on you that she needed,
he gave me like the car very hard to defend those fucking with dudes because I
realize now everyone's a bad ass.
Everyone is.
I almost got in a fight.
I'm just going to fight recently.
A real yeah,
because I just was like my bro,
my drives,
no.
Stober it was in the morning I was going to shoot something for comedy central
and I,
my,
I needed a bathing suit.
So my sisters live on an apartment building a blow Starbucks.
So I like fly in and I kind of block it at two spaces and I,
they're just going to throw my bathing suit to me so they throw it.
And then as I pull out,
I realize I blocked it and it's got pissed.
So he,
um,
he's really pissed as not,
as I pulled out,
he zooms in,
gets out of his car and starts yelling at me.
Now I'm Duco,
I've been in a lot of fist fights,
so I do come from that kind of like mentality of like talk shit.
And that's my mentality at the time.
So I,
I said Talk Shit and let's fight.
I'll fight.
You just ready to fight some dude?
No,
no,
not now.
Not now.
How long ago was this?
This was,
this was like three years ago.
Okay.
You're a different guy now.
Barry,
this moment.
And then the moment happened the next day.
So then he tells me and I wrote out my window and I yelled at him.
I go,
I was just trying to get my bathing suit,
like,
like that's going to fucking like,
he's going to go,
oh,
I didn't know.
Go ahead.
But I was like,
that was my defense.
I'm just getting my fucking bathing suit.
I wasn't being a dick.
And then he goes,
fuck,
you learn how to drive.
And so I'd get out of the car and then I stand up my come out here,
I can stand on the car and I go,
come out here and be a man.
Prove your fucking man.
Oh No.
Oh my God,
you're crazy at a fucking Starbucks.
Now everyone's like,
oh,
do you know how to fight it all?
No,
but I know.
Yeah,
I know how the,
and this was La,
right?
This is la have you do have martial arts training.
None whatsoever.
You don't know how to box.
Never wrestled.
Never box,
never wrestled sparring.
Just fist fights in college and damn dude,
what are you doing?
You crazy.
Exactly.
And it was at that moment that I realized that he walked out,
I would have to fist fight.
Right.
And what if he's good?
He is do,
what do you do if you get out there and you start talking shit to a dude and the
dude just holds his hands up real natural and starts bouncing around on his toes
to get my car drive away or he just pulls out a gun and shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
Is La?
Yeah,
that too.
But it's that moment.
You might need your ass first.
Yeah.
You need that one moment where you go,
all right,
that's never going to happen again.
Yeah.
Why,
why,
why have unnecessary conflict?
You know,
that's an unnecessary moment.
That's like just management right there and management of stress and emotions.
Yes.
Because really you don't even know this guy.
If that was you,
what if you had done this and the guy who you cut off was like your best friend
and you know,
you cut them off and you're like,
fuck,
I can't believe I cut Mike off.
You know,
Mike is my best friend.
Yeah.
You know,
the,
your interaction with this guy is all based on,
you know,
this,
this conflict that you're having.
But those treated though guy,
mine I,
no,
no.
But if you could rewire your brain to try to think like that.
Was he driving a Prius?
Now he's driving a TV douche bag.
I might've done
deal BMW.
I told you I'm on a eight.
Eight count eight so far I've seen eight Prius's flick cigarettes out there when
he owes eight.
That's crazy.
It's amazing.
I,
I started noticing it in San Francisco.
I'm like,
why do I keep seeing these eco cunts throwing cigarettes out their window?
There's some,
they have some weird justification.
So you could also think that you could just own a Prius because you want to save
money on gas.
You don't give a shit about fucking,
yeah,
I swear to God I unplugged this fucking country phone.
Yeah,
it's funny now I sound funny dude.
Yeah.
Hello?
From one planned parenthood Joe.
Planned parenthood.
Yeah,
out of John Mendoza.
It sounds like.
How did you hear my parents have always taken planned parenthood,
you know,
call me buddy,
should you,
you should.
Great place to pick up chicks.
Is the subway right underneath the planned parenthood and get a bunch of sites
where,
what were we talking about before we got cut out?
Yeah.
Don't go and get an if not.
No,
I mean it's like a total hippie thing to say,
well look at that guy as if he's your brother and treat him as such,
but you know a lot of shit can be avoided.
It just with like cool talking to people,
Shit that could just turn your whole life into ugliness.
Oh Dude.
Fucking a new gynecologist punched the one time and killed him.
He fell back on a,
on a thing and Kevin James went to a,
he was a bouncer for a while and he was a bouncer with this dude and a fight
broke out between some drunk,
something happened,
bouncer punched this kid.
The kid fell unconscious and banged his head off the curb and died.
The bouncer fucking college kids trying to make some money.
All of a sudden he's in jail for like years,
you know?
It was like some serious shit.
He got charged with manslaughter.
I think that's a lot of the reason why I wear hats and sunglasses so much.
And I always look at that ground.
I've never could,
especially already don't worry.
I know what,
I don't care.
I don't need to talk to anybody.
If I want to talk to somebody,
I'll go to Yale year know type attitude.
Like I like people.
It's funny when you see those people that hand out things on the streets,
you know like flyers or people like trying to get you to sign things.
When you walk into the grocery store you see that I watched them like go to
every person and I get up and they don't say a word to me.
They like,
cause I purposely sent out a vibe to be like,
don't talk to me.
Yeah,
I'm not happy when they get me in the parking lot of the supermarket when I'm
trying to put my groceries into the truck.
You know,
what are you doing?
This guy comes up to me with his one finger up in the air.
Okay.
Holding it up in the air,
like above his head.
And he points it at me and he goes,
do you have one minute for gay rights?
No.
Do you have one minute for gay rights?
We're talking about lesbian rights.
And I was like,
yeah,
dude,
I'm going to my fucking car.
Get outta here.
This is nonsense.
No one minute for you.
This ain't about gay rights,
man.
You're not going to fix gay rights by me giving you a dollar or by me giving you
my fucking email address.
That's not going to fix gay rights.
What's gonna fix?
Gay Rights is voting and people learning how to be nice to each other and not
being prejudice.
Not Some fucking Weirdo who uh,
costs you in a parking lot with a finger in your face.
Do you have one minute for gay rights?
He was just so pronounced Lee offensively gay,
you know,
with his finger in my face.
Okay guys,
mom and take guys just fucking hate me.
Why?
I don't know.
They see me and I think they just look at me and they're like,
fucking,
that guy was a nightmare in highschool.
Think you're homophobic.
Oh,
in a heartbeat.
On the furthest thing from homophobic.
He looked like a decent bear,
you know,
do a decent bear bears for folks at home that are innocent is what a hairy,
overweight gay man bear.
That's a call.
And they'll know a bunch of people are looking at this going,
oh,
that is a little bit,
it's just show got so gay.
Right.
They're both until he just almost kissed going to gay porn accidentally.
Accidentally.
I've seen a bunch of shit.
I'm by a website,
there's always stuff.
But one time,
uh,
I was uh,
I picked up this girl in Long Island and we went back to her place and she had,
she said,
there's this video that's here that was here when I moved in.
I think it's a porn.
And I go,
Oh yeah.
And so she throws it in and it's these two dudes in the woods and one dude's got
his back against the tree and the other dude is looking at them.
I'm like,
why is he looking at him like that?
I didn't know it was the gay porn.
I thought it was a port put in a lot of backstory out it like this is going to
be a strange story.
I never did like story ones.
I like
the clips just cut right to the bone and I don't need to know that you're a
pizza man.
Okay.
So anyway,
this,
this dude pulls the guy's pants down and starts sucking his cock and I literally
like started hyperventilating.
I was like,
wow.
Like I'd never seen mind you,
you kids today,
you grow up.
This is the age of the Internet.
Your,
you see dude sucking Dick all the time.
I had never seen a man to actually suck a dick until this moment.
And I was probably 22 years old,
somewhere around 2123 so this guy starts talking,
this guy's cock.
And I was like,
wow,
they really do do it.
That's what I,
that's what I thought in my head.
Like I knew what that's what gay was like.
I lived in San Francisco for three years when I was younger.
My,
actually my aunt,
I told this story before,
but my aunt used to get high with these gay guys that live next door and they
used to smoke pot and get naked together and like one guy would play the bongos
and they were really weird and I was like this big muscular black iron is white
little bitch boyfriend and my aunt would go over and smoke pot.
So I grew up with gay people.
Now it didn't bother me.
I didn't know.
But watching the guy actually suck the cock.
I'm like Whoa,
you can't take that back to you are sucking at cock.
I can't believe that.
I could,
couldn't believe that they could get people to do it.
Even if you were gay,
you want people to know that much.
You wouldn't be able to see the gay stuff.
I used to have a joke about you're going to hate this but why would I hate it
cause cause I used to,
I used to say as it looked in the eye and say who's seen a gay porn?
No one.
I said who's seen the UFC?
And then everyone I go,
here's my pitch mixed the two genres,
right?
Fights where the winner gets to fuck the loser in the ass.
I'm not saying anyone would watch the entire fight,
but how hard would you fight if your asshole was on the line?
You would fight hard to share.
No tap house.
No tap outs.
Just the best part that I thought would be after the guy is unconscious watching
Brock Lesnar tried to get hard thing like I just don't want to get hard before I
can put them in the ass.
Come on,
come on,
come on.
So what is that?
Yeah.
What if he takes him down to rape them and the guys out?
He can't get it out.
Can't get it up and he's just sitting there and then the guy starts coming to
it.
He's got a service into my own contest.
They win by tap in tap that ass.
But yeah,
they always get like a vote.
I hate them though.
That's hilarious.
I don't know,
I just thought like UFC,
it brings up the whole,
so gave a two guys rubbing Dixie.
What guys like you like to think it's gay.
I might've thought that when I first thought of it the first time in ever way.
Now you know,
I don't think of it,
but it's funny.
Every time I go to like open mikes and stuff like that.
Then whenever they talk about you have ca that that comes up,
they shut the gates.
That's like Asian drivers are black guys can't tip,
you know?
It's all like,
it's all right there.
It's a hot topic.
It's the both the easiest conclusion to draw,
you know?
Yes.
He's guys in their underwear.
They stop wearing the tight ones.
Tight ones.
The player will still rock the tights.
It was packaged there.
You know what I'm saying?
He just smuggling it.
No.
Did you ever fight in UFC?
No,
I would not.
Never.
I don't think you should ever dabble in fighting.
I think fighting is a very,
very,
very dangerous thing and you should be obsessed with it and it should be your
sole focus.
It shouldn't be,
you know,
a standup comedian slash author slash podiatrist slash UFC fighter.
No one was the last fist fight you got in Lego provoked street.
So I was in high school.
Really?
Yeah.
Now how the time I was in high school,
I was already a martial arts champion.
So I,
I was so scared of getting bullied and kids fucking with me that I just became
obsessed with martial arts.
Yeah.
And so when I was,
you know,
16 was already winning all these,
these big tournaments on a 17 I was the Massachusetts State Championship.
I was finding in the men's divisions when I was a kid,
when I was like 15 and 16 so most of the kids that I knew at the time,
they all knew that I was doing that.
So,
but I would just left me a lot when I was still terrified.
I was still scared.
Even when I was fighting and tournaments,
I was afraid of bullies and getting my ass kicked.
I didn't totally believe that I could kick someone's ass really,
even when I was knocking out grown men and inspiring and you know,
and then,
you know,
having a fucking wars in the gym,
I would still run into bullies.
And you know,
kids that I knew that were like bullies and I'd be scared of him.
I just did.
I didn't want him to fuck with me.
I wanted to make sure I can get away from,
let me just go around the outside.
Like I even when I was winning fights against train fighters are still fucks
with your hand.
Me and my friends that we all got bullied by the same bullies,
you know,
but we're all like the artist's kids,
I uh,
what we'd always do is like,
like draw pictures of them like with Cox and their mouth and stuff like that.
It's just like really like put them around like the bathrooms and like the
girls' bathrooms would throw him in there.
We just turn around the corner and just toss a bunch of drawings in there.
I,
I'll say like,
you know,
copy them or do you just write the same drawing over?
Yeah,
we copied them and then a copy machine.
Yeah.
But we would make it like kind of like currency and they knew we were,
the artists are so much louder than everybody's mind.
We knew.
Same thing,
same thing as yesterday.
Is there a setting so much lower on this board?
If you could look,
come look at it is better than ours.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
But so anyway,
so we would draw a bunch of different ones.
So there was like all these kind of like $5 bill,
$10 bill,
$20 they'll have different kind of currency of bullies,
bullies with Dixon talks and stuff like that.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
I wanted to,
I just pitch the travel channel.
They were just trying to think of ways to promote my new show and I thought I
had the most genius idea.
I was like,
what if you made like busts of bust of me like this big right.
Just my boss and like with my mouth open and it fit over urinal mince like
urinal cages.
So you'd put them in urinals all over the country.
Just me with my mouth open so people could pay them because of my mouth.
I was like,
everyone would fucking talk about those.
And like,
I've thought it would like spread like wildfire and they looked at me like I was
out of my fucking mind.
I'm fairly confident that I would never have come up with that.
But
if you saw one in a bar,
would you not bring it up?
I would never want anybody pissing in any symbolic mouth of mine because I don't
want to give anybody that idea.
I don't want dudes go,
you have no,
after we pushed it,
his mom,
what's fucking me is my hadn't thought it all the way through possible.
John,
you jerk off in his head and I'm going to shit on his chest.
You know,
I don't want to open up the door for anything.
The grading,
it wasn't flushed out,
but I thought it would be like one of those like marketing geniuses.
You would what you would want to give people something that everybody wants and
needs and doesn't really have on them.
Like,
if you want to give them a lighters,
you know,
or something like that would perk to conquer lighters or give them something
that they're gonna use.
So they're going to enjoy the fact that,
oh,
I got this from birth Congo,
like a key chain.
It,
he's a fucking key chain man.
That's silly.
It's just more shit to have in your pocket.
Put Your fucking key in your pocket right now.
But like,
you know,
birth to conquer key chains,
that's not going to come up.
That's not good.
But,
but like maybe a lighter.
No,
especially people who are smokers.
I was,
I told her to print like a thousand stickers and just send them to kids.
That'll then get annoyed if stick their stickers.
Birth the conquered Khan.
He's got his fucking stickers all over my school.
What is that loaded?
What does a thing though that you could use that would really help people
besides like pens and shit like that?
Like what would people in joy,
is there a piece of swag that people would actually be happy to get?
Brian,
you're in new,
all that shit.
Yeah.
You know the thing I would think of iPhone cases.
That's not a bad movie because I mean,
I know so many,
so many chicks that have no iPhone case.
I'm like,
dude,
you're so fucking stupid.
You're going to break this.
You know you're going to draw so dope.
But out of case it does look dope at all.
Their excuses.
It's like,
I know.
I just need,
I just needed,
it's pretty stupid that you have to have a case to.
That bothers the shit out of me.
I think that's so dumb.
I had that little rubber bumper on.
I dropped it shattered.
Really?
Yeah.
They'll get the rubber feet.
That's where I got a good fat rubber one.
Now what about,
what about burnt the conqueror,
Ma magnetic wristbands,
all those holograms.
Bullshit,
bullshit bands.
Those things pass mountain people like go fuck this.
I've seen so many high level fighters wearing those things and makes me so sad.
It's like,
why don't you just take a chicken head and wrap that around your neck?
Do some Voodoo.
Yeah,
but it works.
What does that Brian,
he,
this is like a rubber iPhone case that I got the other day from second Japanese
on listening on iTunes.
He's holding up some sort of,
oh,
you just got that for free?
No,
I didn't get it for free,
but I'm just saying if you feel it,
this is like a cheap,
that is a cheap product.
Well how they cost like 30 bucks though,
Dude.
Yeah,
but that much or markup.
If you go to Ebay,
if you go to Amazon you can get like a box of these killings have.
So how much do you think that would cost is?
Probably like a dollar.
Well,
I think probably just the part alone.
I'd probably say like not even a dollar 13 something like that.
So how did you come up with the doctor?
Because it seems more official does,
right?
If you added an extra number in there,
I bet there's a company on the Internet that you can print out your own iPhone
cases.
What about birth?
Congress sunscreen and we'll package the sunscreen.
That's not a bad idea.
As long as you know that it like give you cancer or something.
Cause I read some crazy shit about sunscreen actually contributing to cancer and
some people.
Okay,
great.
Yeah,
that's all lather and sunscreen.
I do too,
man.
Fucking,
I have a friend of mine,
he's got skin cancer right now.
Oh,
I had a big,
big chunk of meat removed from his head.
Now how did he leave?
Like itchy or here's the scary thing.
He went to a dermatologist and the dermatologist said nothing.
The dermatologist said,
I don't think you should worry about it.
And then a year later he went to another dermatologist and it turns out skin
cancer and it was pretty deep.
They had a really dig into his head to cut it out.
Wow.
That's scary because I mean I have this one little,
I'm a moly motherfucker.
I have one,
this one mole on my bag.
That always feels so weird.
It's like crusty feeling sometimes and then I went to the dermatologist and
they're like,
oh no,
that's fine.
Here,
look at these pictures.
See that?
That's what you wanted to look out for,
where it looks like red dots and it's like all crazy looking and I'm like,
okay.
But I've always thought,
no,
that's not right.
That's tactile 10th I'm a high bone mass and hypochondriac.
Oh,
I found a fucking ingrown hair on my arm one time and because I just hung out
with Schimmel,
I was like,
I got fucking non Hodgkin's lymphoma.
There's no sports.
Oh my God.
I was in a fucking convince myself.
Whole flight home went straight to the Dr. Chen.
She's looked at it.
She was,
it's an ingrown hair.
Holy Shit Dude.
Check this out.
I had an ingrown hair in my belly button.
Do you remember this?
This is like four or five and this show turn gay or oh my God,
I got to see this.
You have an ingrown toenail.
Anything ingrown that's pissing,
I'm dying to see you.
Don't you haven't typed in Bob,
fly bought fly extractions.
I want one so bad,
but just the idea to pull it out.
Maybe I don't want one.
When I want my wife to get one,
we can pull it out.
All the awesome.
Let me see your,
I know he'll have it now.
This is like four or five years ago and it had a weird puss thing going on son.
You don't go,
you don't do that.
I'll get,
if I get anything like a good pimple.
All my gets swelled up my belly button to the point where you can even put your
finger in it.
And then one day it just filled up with blood and yellow stuff and whites.
Careful about staph infections.
And this is for anybody that listens to the podcast.
Please,
if you have any weird infection on your body that you know,
maybe it's a spider bite,
I don't know what it is.
Go to a fucking doctor and get that checked out because you could fucking die.
Staph infections are scary shit.
Did you guys do,
you probably don't know the comics thins.
Roy Johnson,
he's from Tampa,
right?
So I'm going on Facebook one day and I click on it and the,
and the thing has post his doctors say,
it looks like I'll keep my leg.
And then now I'm like,
what the fuck?
Right.
So I go to his page and I start clicking back older posts to find out like what
happened?
So I'll go back and like two months,
two weeks later,
and,
and it starts like he's at the Dayton funnybone and he's like,
yeah.
So,
um,
I got a weird bite on my leg last night.
Uh,
well I wonder if it's a spider bite.
I'm going to get some calamine lotion next day.
It's getting worse the day after that.
Okay.
This is really starting to concern me.
The day after that I'm having a hard time and like,
you can see him getting worse and worse and worse.
And then he ends up in a hospital,
he's like,
Dr Sale,
keep my leg.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck.
It's like this guy.
It's like this.
What was it?
I have no idea.
And it must've been Murcia.
It must've been that it that there's a crazy strain of staph.
We talked about the antibiotics,
Brian,
but people not taking their antibiotics and the full dose that doesn't kill the
bacteria and it creates things.
He's antibiotic resistant strains of of infection and staph is one of the
scariest ones,
man.
Oh fuck yeah.
There's ID Eric who apparently has it real bad.
Who the Baywatch Chick Diamond Ericho shut up.
Has she got Marissa?
She got it real bad.
Apparently it was in the news like choosing like,
like really bad shape.
I was worried about that at Barry's bootcamp.
Like give up cause I don't think they clean it well this is what you got to make
sure you know when you ever get any sort of scratch.
There's a,
there's a company called defense soap that has a bunch of different solvents or
solves and all these different things and they're all natural oils that kill and
any look funky and factions,
but any open wound and he opens craft,
you gotta clean that.
That has to be cleaned and you have to make sure you put something on it.
You know this,
these ointments and south,
they're all like natural.
It's all like eucalyptus oil and tea tree oil kills all funky shit.
Yeah.
You know,
just give yourself a fighting chance that dudes run around with like deep
scratches.
They don't do anything about it and something you don't clean it and then it
gets infected.
Like you can't fucking lose your arm like that.
That's no joke man.
I know a dude who got one in his elbow and his elbow was fucked up.
He got it in Jujitsu,
didn't own it,
was hurt him,
didn't do anything for a while.
And by the time you went to a doctor,
you know he's a tough guy as Australian dude.
By the time I went to a doctor,
it's too late and had this giant hole in his arm cause his arm had swollen up.
This,
these monstrous looking thing is twice the size of a normal elbow fuck as fat.
It happened Ari Shaffir too.
Or You got one on his knee and we were playing pool and I saw him limping around
the pool table.
I go,
what the fuck is going on?
And he goes,
I got bit by a spider.
And as soon as he said that to me,
I said,
oh fuck.
You know,
I had had staff once and I was lucky that somebody pointed it out to me.
I didn't know what it was.
I got it really,
really early.
It was just a,
a few pimples on my leg.
And my friend Tate looked at it.
He goes,
dude,
what does that on your leg?
And I go out,
I don't know.
It was,
it's,
it's or something.
He goes,
I think you got staff,
man,
you gotta go get that checked.
That checked out.
And what it is is,
uh,
it's follicular,
follicular Itis,
I forget,
I forget how it's what the official term is,
but when you see likely follicles that are like little infected follicles,
that's the beginning.
That's the beginning of a staph infection.
And it could be nothing.
It could go away or it can get ugly and be nasty.
And Ariz had turned into like this swollen posy looking thing that looked like
he had been bit by something and it was just a rampant staph infection.
How do you get rid of it?
Well,
he had to go on some serious antibiotics and he got it again.
He got staff again like a year later.
How's he getting it?
Like Joseph,
where he got it from Jujitsu.
Okay,
got it.
From Jujitsu.
And that happens in Jujitsu and the way it happens is you're getting scratched
and scraped and you know you're sparring and when you're sparring you're going
pretty much full clip on each other and you know you get cuts and you need
scratch on the ground and,
and if you don't wash yourself,
like Ari would just like fucking,
he was just like not take a shower at all even that night.
And he would have like 10 dudes,
rape,
sweat all over him leaking into various holes in his body.
That's true.
And
bangs chicks in that bed and by the way,
are he changes his sheets.
No bullshit.
Once every six months he went six months without changing the sheets.
No,
I think it was even longer than that because it was like a very long time.
He wonders what,
why the fuck he gets staff?
Yo Dude,
you gotta clean your house.
I love that video of his asshole clam.
Oh my God,
it's the best.
So strengths and defines what hemorroids really are.
Like I didn't know what they bought is your butt's popping out from the inside.
How do you do standup with that in the back of your pants?
How do you show it to everybody and not give a fuck and sit on my wallet and
Hari is already sitting on a golf ball.
I never was comfortable though.
It's like squishy.
It's probably like,
you know,
like those things you put on your end,
you're an air mattress.
The doctor Scholls Yellen,
Kelly donating,
his mind's told it works totally different than lying.
So talking to him about getting home,
smoking weed to get a prescription to for flying.
So I have a terrible fear of flying and he's like,
dude,
you just got to take one of these gel tabs and I'm telling you man,
like him and Ralphie.
Yeah.
Two people that I just don't under a player,
just take two of these.
You don't listen,
don't listen.
They're fucking being dicks.
Like they don't mean to,
but like I just,
I took like half of one and was melted abreast trip.
One of those little things,
if you get ahold of those pit jammies,
those you take a half.
Just don't take your a Oh,
don't eat any.
Yeah.
Don't eat anything if you didn't make it yourself,
man.
It's just too hard to know the dosage.
You've got to regulate that shit.
Not fucking like dudes that work in Intel making microchips fucking lab coats
on.
So asshole,
a tie dye tee shirt and a goofy ponytail and he's throwing some shit into a bowl
and if he's making it,
he clearly has a high tolerance is,
or who am I going to make this two fucking kids.
Exactly.
I,
there's a dude that came to visit us and uh,
he came to visit us at the John Lovitz club and he gave me some shit on me and
Joey after the show,
we both like just sat there and Joey always leaves.
He always lead.
Oh wait,
go out.
If I go on stage,
I know that it's a second show.
By the time I get offstage,
Joey's got,
I got offstage,
I'm saying hi,
a saint by the staff.
Thank you everybody.
Bubba blog gathering all my shit and I see jelly sitting in a chair.
Yeah,
I ain't got a lot of your dog.
I ain't moving.
I moving Joe Rogan.
That's how high and you're not going anywhere either stay here with me.
Cocksucker the whole time he was sitting there watching a jet when you're on
stage sweating like hand going like a thousand miles of no,
just to sweating.
He would look at me and those r's,
you know,
he's like looking at you like a deployant being these motherfuckers in their
cookies,
man.
They were too strong.
[inaudible] uh,
they had,
he like these,
what are those called?
Biscottis the guy told me only eat a half our,
he ate a whole one and Joey ate one and a half of them.
Juliet,
one and a half.
The guy says,
eat a half Geragos
I laugh in the face of danger.
He just ate all of it.
Yeah,
no way.
No.
What happens to your brain when you get is getting too high?
Like getting too drunk?
No.
It's when you get really,
really high,
especially if you eat it,
it's a really psychedelic,
it's very,
it's a,
it's really introspective and it really brings up your past and you start
thinking about all kinds of weird shit about your childhood and things that you
did.
You know,
that you're upset that you did to someone when you were like seven.
you'll,
you,
you just start really tripping out about weird shit.
And it's,
it's much more,
uh,
it's,
it's like a much deeper,
much more like psychedelic trip than just smoking it.
When you smoke it,
you can get really high.
You get paranoid and get hyper aware.
You start feeling really vulnerable.
We stopped being really sensitive to shit.
But when you eat it,
you start hallucinating.
Especially when you close your eyes,
when you eat it and you close your eyes.
Dude,
I always,
for me,
for whatever reason,
it's cartoons fucking,
that's what I see.
I see these really bizarre alien,
impossible.
Describe cartoons fucking and I can never exactly see what they look like cause
whatever they look like right now is not what they look like a second from now.
Yeah.
Just keep morphing and changing and it's like some sort of these alien cartoons.
Fucking,
that's what I see every time I closed my eyes when I get super big.
That's what I know.
If I've eaten like a pot cookie,
that's what I know.
I'm deep in the terrorist zone.
Really?
Yeah.
You get into that.
That's strange place of,
it's almost feels that you feel like you are now in another dimension.
Like you've entered into an alien world.
You look at the world around you,
the mechanical world,
like airplanes and pilots and stewardesses and cars and trolleys,
and you look at all that shit and the mechanical interfacing and all becomes
like,
you become like super aware of it all and it feels like an alien world.
You can see there's a world all around you that you've totally taken for granted
that is completely bizarre.
The world of you climbing into a metal box with these squishy rubber tires
connected to this hard Pavan that they've created and molded over the earth,
and you're,
you're in this box,
and while this is happening,
the giant fucking nuclear explosion that lights everything up and you're
spinning around and going a million miles an hour through the fucking universe,
it's,
it's just too much,
man.
And you have to compartmentalize your life.
And what pot does is it doesn't let you compartmentalize.
You can't say,
well,
I've got to get the kids to school.
You know,
pop,
pop goes,
yeah,
you do.
But look at what life really is.
Look at space.
It goes on forever.
Inside every galaxy there's a black hole inside.
Every black holes in another universe filled with hundreds of billions of
galaxies,
each with a black hole,
each with another universe,
with hundreds of billions of galaxies.
And the,
the,
the whole massive at all just starts fucking overwhelming
you.
That's,
that's,
that's the problem with pot.
That's why people think like,
you know,
people go,
oh,
it makes me paranoid.
You know,
it's,
you should be paranoid.
If you were really smart,
you would realize a,
the shit all ends,
everyone's going to,
it's going to stall for all of us are trying to get me into an anxiety attack.
Jesus Christ.
That's something that we ignore.
You know,
I think we should appreciate the moment,
but we should be aware that it's temporary,
you know,
and to deny it and just to put it in the back,
that's not helping you because then when the pot comes on,
you know,
when you get super paranoid about that,
what you super paranoid about us,
about something you haven't really addressed in your own mind,
you haven't come to grips with it.
It's a real fucking thing that one day you will find out,
is there a god?
Is there a devil?
Is there fucking space aliens that take you away in their crafts,
right?
Or is this one step in an endless cycle of things that you can't even recognize
what the next one is?
It's so bizarre and alien.
This is alien man.
This,
this world that we live in.
If we didn't live in this world,
we were some sort of an empty,
rational objections,
uh,
objective being,
you know,
that was like looking at human culture.
We would say this is that this way to live is the craziest thing ever.
That's why,
that's why if I ever get really rich,
I'm moving to Idaho,
I'm buying a mountain,
I'm making a huge rock rock sculpture of myself with paintings of like it's
carved into the mountain of what I did.
Like real outrageous stories.
Only thing that's going to be left that is going to go pharaoh,
Pharaoh crises cause that's all his left men.
That's all that's left and all the steel crumbles.
What's going to be me crazy horse and the fucking four presidents and they'll be
like,
who is this hurt?
How dope is that crazy horse structure?
They're still working on my thing.
I'll be doing that shit to forever.
Joe.
Let's do this.
Okay,
I will.
I will spearhead this.
I will quit comedy tomorrow.
Okay.
I don't know a lot of money.
All,
I needed to like a bunch of dynamite down and I just want to do you know how to
do this?
No.
Figure this shit out to figure it out.
Lewis and Clark made it across the fucking country.
I've been watching this new show,
I think it's called the wild within.
It's a new show on the dude.
I watched it last night for the first time I saw the ads and I started t voting
it.
Fuck it's awesome man.
Guide.
And he went to Lewis and Clark way through Montana,
pitbull hunting for fucking,
uh,
born next week.
Jesus Christ.
Like old school.
We're taking some pimples.
Were getting a boar dude.
I had a dog that was trained for that shit.
I had this Hawaiian pit pole that they used for wild hog hunting.
Who is crazy frank.
You remember frank?
Frank was crazy.
There was a door.
I could not stop that door from wanting to attack other animals.
It was bread.
Just go after hog.
So he was like super,
super aggressive,
was a tremendous pain in the ass.
Now how's your daughter?
Would the girls,
oh,
they're great dogs that I have now are very,
like the Johnny,
the big one.
The mastiff is very calm.
He's,
you know,
he's,
he was like the guy who bred him,
bred dogs for fear factor and he really is conscientious about how he mixes
them.
It make sure that dogs that are aggressive to people or even other dogs,
they never get to breed.
So we only breeds the best personalities and he's been doing it for generation
after generation.
So he really is and he's very proud of it.
So as dogs,
I'm like the best temperament.
Like I went over his house and his dogs,
like they're these giant things but they're so calm and friendly and they come
over to you to check you out and assess and make sure,
okay,
let me just make sure you're cool.
Okay.
Come on in.
Come on.
And really what?
I want one of those loud.
Yup.
I wanted an arching Argentinian master.
Those are crazy.
You've got to be careful of those and why I didn't know.
And then,
and then I submitted,
I sent an email to the lady and then she sent back a questionnaire and the idea
of kids first.
Yeah,
first question,
do you have kids?
And I was like,
yeah,
second question,
do you plan on sleeping with a dog?
And I was like,
I don't understand the second bar with them.
You have to buy what it is.
It's a lot of didn't want before.
Before Mrs Rogan moved in,
I used to sleep with the dogs really asleep at two pimples on my bed.
Yeah.
They love it.
They love sleeping with you.
They love you,
man dogs.
You know when you have a real relationship with dogs like that,
they really are like the sort of sub human baby that you have.
It's like,
it's not quite human.
You don't love him as much as that.
But you know there's an affectionate like loving bond between you and a dog and
it will ever since you and Callen like la two weeks ago,
last week said like you were guys were talking about crazy as it that were
riding horses.
Like I started looking at animals like just sitting in my house like,
it's weird.
I got fucking dominion over that bitch.
What's weird is when they can kill you and they don't know,
like when you have a pit bull or in my master,
if he could kill me,
I've,
I've worked with chimpanzees maybe four or five times.
I had a chimpanzee and adult chimpanzee on my,
all my shoulders with both ears,
him,
his hands.
Oh No.
For fucking spike TV.
And I was like making 13 grand an episode.
My possibility of my nose being bitten off.
A real good possibility.
I've worked with Jason,
a male,
male chimpanzee are sitting on my neck.
John the John Morton is one of my,
one of EPA I've worked with a ton of times,
has a picture of it and he's just got both my ears in his hands.
I worked with a bear.
[inaudible]
who's a fucking beast.
Like how big?
Like he was like a seventh grader when he's just seven 4,100 pounds.
Uh,
yeah.
Me.
Yeah.
So it was sort of an adolescent.
I'll wrestle a bear one time for that.
Hochberg show,
Dude.
Thus the fucking scariest thing I've ever done in my life.
Did you ever see the video of that guy who is a trainer and the bear kills?
I killed his brother or his cousin.
I think it was his brother.
It's this,
it might be the same bear I worked with.
Really?
Cause I worked with the bear.
That was,
it was a movie bear.
She was like the bear that fucking,
uh,
fought.
Will Ferrell in the movie.
Semi-Pro.
Really?
I think this is the bear we're talking about.
Dude,
you're killed somebody.
So they,
hold on.
Let's,
let's find this out real quick because I think,
I think his name was Bam Bam.
Or it's from Bambam's family.
One of the bears that we fought that day was named Bam Bam.
I know that.
But I think that is podcasts.
It's filled with bear.
Semi-Pro bear kills trainer.
Yeah.
That's the first thing that comes up.
It,
what was the bear's name,
I think is,
is either
rocky,
rocky and Bam.
Bam.
Where the massive animal who are named rocky is being put through obedience
exercises,
was being put through obedience exercises while he just decided to just bite
this dude on.
Where's it?
Let me see a picture of where it is.
That looks like where it was is in California.
Um,
yes.
Yeah.
Big Bear.
We had to drop out.
We had to drive out to the fucking bear.
This bear killed some.
This we,
it's,
yeah.
There's only like four bears you can work with.
It's like fucking black black acts.
So you worked with this murderer bear.
That was a really good job.
We're going to pass by,
but in that book,
that's so true.
I wasn't even thinking about it.
I apologize.
I like how you claimed it though.
You like stop.
Stop.
That was a good line.
I like that.
So you go to this.
How's Al Sharpton keep getting work?
What the fuck,
man?
You guys can't do better than that guy.
That guy's the same as man in America.
No one's killing him.
Oh,
so ridiculous.
No white supremacy is going to kill him.
They love what he did carry.
So see.
Yeah,
he's so buffoonish.
She gets into this window's open.
So chopped and walk by the comedy store one night.
And we were hammered.
It was me and God,
I forgot.
I think Ari was there.
Eddie Bravo was definitely there.
And,
uh,
and he,
he's walking by and as he's walking by like Al Sharpton,
we all just start yelling.
How,
how Sharpton's a Pab how shopped in port that mother Fucker,
everyone's yelling at like five different dudes.
Go get yours out.
Fuck those dummies.
And No,
and he's like kind of waving and not knowing how to respond.
And we're just like letting you know,
we know you're a crook,
but go ahead.
Go get it.
He did trickier how he got his,
uh,
is the tomorrow broadly style?
His is relaxed hair relaxed.
No,
he used to look like fucking buckwheat.
Right.
And then,
uh,
and then,
um,
godfather of soul,
James Brown was that I can get you a meeting with the president and we can get
a,
you know,
we'll get in there tomorrow.
I think it was like,
I want to say it was Nixon or fucking Reagan or Carter.
James Brown just called the office and was like,
we had a meeting.
I saw it in the movie,
good hair.
We've got a meeting.
And he goes,
listen,
I ain't taking you to meet the president if your hair,
he got his hair.
Oh,
the
movie.
Good hair.
Best fucking movie.
I've seen in the longest time,
you cannot go through TSA and not guess if black women have fucking weaves.
It makes you reassess black woman entirely.
Best movie.
So anyway,
so they on hurt Bert.
I'd fucking,
I had,
I had broken my ribs.
I got mauled by a bull.
Whoa.
What's online?
So online,
just type in hurt.
Burt Rodeo saw from your show is hurt.
Blurred.
There's one I did right after the x show where I met you like 10 years ago.
So stepped on your foot and it hit your side or broke my ribs and broke my foot.
So school didn't teach me a fucking thing on the show.
They just bring me in and go.
So today you're going to be a rodeo clown.
I go,
what do I need to know?
And then just stay away from the bowl and just let the bull loose.
Put me in the makeup.
Just fucking broke.
It just mauled me.
And so they're like,
you're alive.
No,
do you have no fucking idea?
You have no fucking idea.
Who is responsible for this show?
Mark Cronin,
who is the producer's Cronin,
the guy who does a,
he did celebrity reality on VH one nine d 2000.
Oh.
So they really weren't hip to how dangerous all the shit was.
It was done through Fox and they were literally like,
I remember them going,
um,
it's simple.
We'll just pay him as a contestant and then we'll give him the rest of his money
for being a producer.
So my eye was covered because you're a contestant.
Technically I was like,
I was like a reality show contestant.
So I was covered under that insurance clause and then I was just paid like the
rest,
like 80% of the money as a producer and executive producer on the show.
Wow.
So that,
but the idea was it was,
it's,
you can't sue yourself cause you're a producer.
Right?
It's your idea and it's the most brilliant show that never took off.
It was,
it was jack asked me,
he's dirty jobs.
You want to see it,
Joe,
I would go out and I would do,
I would take dirty,
I would take dangerous jobs for a day.
So it was a professional football player,
MMA fighter,
hockey player,
dominatrix games.
You actually have an MMA fight.
No,
I just fucking fought three Gracie's at once and they just beat me up.
So that was what I watched that man.
That's uh,
what is like,
like putting your fucking body on the line like that.
Although I was young and I was in and I just was like,
and it then,
that was the theme of entertainment at the time was that like jackass.
I had done this ass wax and like 2000 that had blown up before jackass.
It's the funniest thing I've ever done in my entire life.
Cause I swear to God,
if you're listening to this waxy type in Bert Bert ass wax and it's,
it's longer cause that's the way segments were made then.
But it is the funniest thing I've ever done in the funniest.
Wow.
Like share got ahold of it and started passing around to people and like it
talks to clip of the year.
I mean it was like that's the reason I'm going to fucking,
I literally,
everything I've ever done is just kind of like fallen.
It happened along as this clip us too long.
But uh,
so then,
then,
and then we did the bowl thing.
I broke my ribs and so we had to kind of stay in the city cause I couldn't
really travel.
And they're like,
so after you broke your ribs,
did you,
they give you time off,
say,
okay,
heal up and then you go right back at it.
They gave me no like two weeks and then two weeks and then two weeks off and yet
broken ribs,
two weeks I just laid in dead on bed.
Rest.
Didn't do anything right,
but you can't just go back out with broken ribs can you can they can fracture
and become,
you know,
embedded in your organs.
Yeah.
We didn't really think a lot of this through God damn dude.
When I was a football player,
we were doing helmet to helmet contact.
I basically shot up porn one day when I was the one I was the dominate trick
camp.
I basically shot a porn.
Really?
I mean it was naked and this girl was just fucking doing everything she could to
my junk,
like putting weights on my balls and,
and it was insane.
It was insane.
It was,
there was,
it was the wild west of reality television because what was huge at the times,
fear factor,
right?
Everyone's eating shit and jumping out and shit and like crazy.
And so it was this next level stuff where you didn't know you could just host
something and be charming and people would stick around for that and you just
had to take it to the next,
you had to fucking try to bring it and you're competing with that doggy dog like
jackass.
So he thought,
I mean,
yeah,
it was like Doh,
craziest shit.
So then the,
the opus,
not the opens,
but like,
the height of it was towards him when they were like,
Hey,
do you want to fight a bear?
And I was like,
I was like,
who does that for a living?
And they're like,
you do on Thursday?
Oh my God.
Sure enough,
man.
They just took me out and fucking,
dude,
what was that like?
A ta terrifying cause terrifying because you see the berries totally wild.
Like he's jumping up and down and there's like a crew there.
And I,
and I gotten this,
by this time I realized they don't have a really good and give you shit about my
safety because I'd already had gotten fucked up by the bull.
So what they're looking for is the end is to hurt Bert Bert to be heard at the
end.
So,
um,
so then,
I mean it's,
it's a little bit,
it's a little bit of a bit,
it's not a bit,
but it's,
the story is a story.
The,
um,
I get there and the trainers like this how we'll do it.
Um,
take these and he hands me five marshmallows.
He was on the bears,
not looking,
take a marshmallow and put in your mouth and then casually walk in front of the
bear and,
and show him the marshmallow like hall and allow the bear the,
an opportunity to engage you and take the marshmallow Outta your mouth with his
mouth.
This way he learned to trust you.
And I'm like,
fuck that.
Like who needs that trust?
Like money from him.
Oh my God,
but you don't know any better at the time.
I'm 28 years old,
maybe 29 and I did it and then he goes,
all right,
we're ready.
I go,
whoa.
What the fuck was that like when that bear tongued you felt like you were making
out with a homeless person?
Like just fucking bear lips look like a 17 foot woman's vagina.
Just going ear to Iran.
You just call horns giant teeth and just tongue right behind the margin when he
suck out.
Knowing that that bear went and killed somebody after that.
Uh,
I don't know.
I think it's probably like the guys who did miss their flight on nine 11.
Like you don't think about it,
you don't go like,
cause you'd I didn't die so I'm like you're the appetizer.
Yeah Dude.
But yeah,
it's the uh,
I mean the entire experience was like terrifying.
We ended up fighting and then they go,
so look,
if you're in trouble,
just say marshmallow cause then that's your safe word and we'll get you out
marshmallow.
Yeah.
And so that fucking farm began the fight.
I'm like fucking marshmallow marshmallow.
And they're the bears just throwing me around.
I'm like marshmallow.
And then the bear put my face in his chest and I couldn't breathe and then,
and then he spun me doggy style and fucking had me in a bear hug where you're
like helpless.
And then I just started looking at the crew and the trainer and I'm like,
marshmallow,
give me the fuck outta here.
Marshmallow.
And the trainers like go limp.
I'm like,
please be talking to me right now.
And not the bear.
There's a bear cock climate marshmallow.
But yeah,
that's the,
I mean that's technically how it went down.
So they didn't save,
you know,
I went lip and slid out the bear and then the bear ended up sitting on my face
and then my wife,
they put a marshmallow in her mouth and the bear got off and then they pulled me
away.
Oh my God.
You let your wife get killed.
I didn't know where he was still worked up like that.
She did it.
And then it went into cranes.
Lions that day,
Tamed Four Lions do fucking Washington.
Elephant.
I mean literally what's,
wow Herbert
was the probably the greatest show.
No one ever saw God damn dude,
you're giving me anxiety.
Just listen to these stories.
So why is it somebody with such anxiety?
It seems like you have a lot of anxiety and stuff that do all these crazy shows.
Cause you also do a show where you like write the craziest rollercoasters and
you do all these intense things,
but it seems like you wouldn't,
it seems like you'd be cooking shows or something.
I don't know.
I don't know why they,
I don't know how I got these jobs.
Like I just got them like,
but I don't,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know why they go to me.
I think.
How did you get the first one?
I got to get hurt.
Berg.
I go,
got her books out of the ass wax and then so the ass wax was for,
what the heck?
Show those for the actual,
yeah.
Okay.
Now I remember the EC show.
We funniest fucking two minutes of television when Joe was on,
cause Gary Valentine,
we all went into Gary's greenroom,
me,
you and Kevin's last men and Jerry,
Jeff Salzman and,
and we were talking and bullshitting and one of the producers came in and
they're like,
so here are the questions we are going to ask Joe.
And Gary's like,
fuck that.
I've known Joe forever.
We're going to be fine.
We're just gonna go out there and riff.
Do you remember this at all?
Sort of.
So we go out,
it's me and Gary and you and you sit down and Gary and Gary was,
I love him like a brother,
but he was the worst host in the world,
the worst.
So he goes,
all right,
welcome back.
I got my buddy Joe Rogan.
I'm known Joe Forever.
How are you doing Joe?
And you're like,
like,
just like pretty good Gary.
And he's like,
oh right.
Oh right.
Yeah.
Okay.
He just loved it.
And then I was like,
so Joe,
you are doing the MMA thing now?
And you're like,
yeah.
And he goes,
hey Joe,
yellow husband and that man,
you always been into that and it was so comfortable to do it again.
You don't remember this at all,
so let's do it again.
So then they go,
okay,
Gary.
And he's like,
they gave him the questions and he's like,
don't worry.
Don't worry.
Fuck no more.
I don't even fucking worry.
I got this,
I got this.
Come on Joe.
We'll just,
uh,
I'll get you in one of your bits.
Okay.
All right.
Hey,
we're back.
I'm here with Joe Rogan Jello and then Joe forever.
Joe I haven't seen in a while.
And you're like,
yeah.
And he's like,
you've been on the road and you're like,
pretty much.
He's like,
great.
Ah,
ah,
ah.
And I'm fucking laughing my tits off next to Gary and Gary's like,
ah,
ah.
And then you're like,
then they're like,
take it again.
And then you're like,
as we about this,
as we [inaudible] curious like gay,
that's where we'll go.
That's where we'll go.
But it ended up being fine.
I completely forgot about this until you just brought it up.
This is like an old dusty memory.
I'm going,
I'm like,
I'm in a corner of an addict right now with a broom going.
Is that what that is?
Yeah.
How clean that fucking get a flashlight.
You have a flashlight.
It was so clunky.
That would have been erased forever.
If you give me like a piece of paper and said,
describe your appearance on the x show.
Something really crazy happened with Gary Valentine.
I would've wrote,
never went on that show.
I don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Do you have a car?
Is it that online anywhere?
No,
those were the outtakes that they'll never use.
Show was like a maximum.
It was,
it was,
they were trying to do like a maxim,
like Maxim magazine,
sort of a TV show.
They were trying to do hot,
sexier Mancho wasn't the guy studs,
wasn't he a part of that?
Mark Carlo?
Yes.
He's actually a really cool dude.
He,
he was,
do you remember studs?
No.
Studs was a show that was the most ridiculous dating show like ever.
Oh yes.
And it was like the most arrogant guys and the most co,
it was like the f one of the first looks into reality TV.
Probably didn't recognize it because it was a,
it was sort of a,
uh,
you know,
a show.
I mean it was like,
you know,
it's a dating show.
We didn't recognize that it was reality TV.
It was a,
yeah.
Marked Carla and then he got fired.
That Guy Justin from like the movie with Alicia Silverstone and you remember
clueless.
He was the pretty boy.
I don't remember.
Got fired.
And then John Weber got fire to me and Gary Ballantine abroad on,
oh that's right.
You guys came in at the very end and we were,
and that's how I met Stan hope cause it was up between me,
Gary Valentine,
Doug,
Stan hope and some guys,
Scott Henry.
Wow.
If you stick around in Hollywood long enough,
man,
you'll have some crazy stories.
They just accumulate.
I remember,
I remember going to the Improv one time and Stan hope was on stage and I don't
know if he saw me or if he didn't,
but he ended up doing like 15 minutes on me,
like just,
just making fun of like a,
but it was very sad.
It was the show.
What was it from the show?
The AKC show.
And he goes,
he was just talking about a shitty show on television that they give to a
younger comic cause he has some heat generated behind them and do,
that's what it's like.
But it was like,
it was really funny.
It was murdering and then I was in the back and I go and I'm sitting there like
I wonder if he knows I'm here.
And then,
and then at the very end is like,
don't get me wrong Bert Kreischer you're a nice guy,
I'm sure,
but I want to see you one week and fucking Iowa when it's snowing and you can't
leave your hotel and there's only,
there's only an Arby's d next door to you and you got to fucking drink wine just
to get through the and like does this whole bit.
And then I'm in the back of them just like I'm fucking leaving.
Cause I was like,
so then so then cut to like four by four years later I'm in Sacramento,
soulless,
empty,
like in the fucking Taffy district or wherever the fucking places and I eat,
I'm just empty and I'm drinking a lot and I email Stan hope and I'm like,
I wonder if I can reach out to the Duke.
Cause that's comics are all like you'd know each other.
So I email Stan hope and like 20 minutes later I get a message back long,
like a long like Oh,
welcome to the quickening.
And then he just emailed me now and then like how you doing baby girl?
Stan hope called me up the other day.
Pie drunk called me in like I tried to like I realized like right when we
started talking,
you know he wanted to talk,
I want an to and he got in an altercation which Janeane Garofalo on the green
room.
Paul prevents his Green Room.
So I wanted to hear like his version up.
Well,
so turtles do dude off a little.
By the way,
are you really fucking show turn?
It feels like it's 1993 right?
Oh my gosh.
She looks so good right now.
We'll go ahead and for real.
Yeah,
she stopped drinking.
She looks at what you're into you or any of that?
Look at all the choices.
Maybe I am my West Traci lords in our prime or Juni Grovo.
Whoa,
Laura's fuck.
Definitely going to Jane.
How often though?
I would've been green in 93 chase him.
Traci Lords.
You don't think it's hot?
Uh,
no.
I don't know what is wrong.
He used to fuck blonde checks all the time.
She's got brown hair.
Oh,
I thought she had blonde hair.
I didn't even notice how the fuck could you wait,
wait,
wait.
So what happened was Dan open to Garafolo.
Okay.
Um,
apparently hello on her first set after nine 11 went on stage at the laugh stop
in Houston.
And according to Stan Hope,
what she said is that you,
you know,
everybody should just back the fuck off and Noam Chomsky should back the fuck
off and leave George Bush alarm because this is obviously a crazy situation and
you know,
and the guys doing the best he can.
And Stan hope was saying that he was very disappointed because he went to see
her expecting some like really biting social commentary into Stan hope was doing
this bit about nine 11 that,
you know,
he's really sticking his neck out there.
He was like,
you know,
where was your,
I guess your God takes Tuesday off.
You know who's doing this thing about all these people like praying for God and
how this,
this came through even in,
you know,
in spite of all these people that were there,
there's religious fervor,
any of this big like,
you know,
anti warp thing that he was working on.
And you know,
he was really into it.
And so when he went and saw [inaudible] and she's like saying,
you know,
give George Bush break,
I thought I was not at him.
So he brought it up on the show.
Apparent fucking love.
Doug Stanhope.
And I talked to Jamie Kilstein and Kilstein saw it and he gave me his version of
it.
And then I talked to Doug and I got this fucking version,
you know,
Doug gave me the drunk man version.
He was hammered when I talked to him.
It was a really crazy conversation because Doug and I,
we have these conversations where,
you know,
we'll like,
like we'll talk like every few months.
And it's like,
okay,
we're yet,
what are you thinking about?
And then when we're talking,
it's like,
you know,
this doesn't make sense and that doesn't make sense.
And then what happens and you know,
what's the point and even concentrating on any of this.
Right,
exactly.
I'm there too and we'll have like these weird conversations,
you know,
we're just trying to like how much have you been trying to figure out in life in
the last three months since we last talked.
And then we try to like figure out,
you know,
if either one of us has come to any conclusions that make you happy and the
middle of this,
he goes xy,
anything.
Is there anything that gives you hope,
anything that gives you hope?
And I was just sitting there going,
wow,
what a strange conversation.
I'm sober,
completely sober.
He's fucked up drunk and he's going to just anything that gives you hope,
maybe he's thinking of a tagline for himself.
You should have said the fleshlight.
Yeah.
Fucking gives me hope.
15% off now Goodall website.
No.
What was,
um,
like when his,
his version of it,
I mean he just was relaying exactly what he saw and he saw that.
We thought it was disappointing that she didn't take a stand and he's not
attacking her.
Just telling her,
but you know what aren't quite honestly after nine 11 who the fuck knew exactly
what happened?
And who knows.
Still I have a real issue with people that want to argue about nine 11 and it's
fucking inside job or you know,
it was just no where the government would have done that either argument where
you're so God damn shore,
you know that whole thing is just a,
a bunch of puzzles.
There's a bunch.
I watched that Jesse Ventura show and I don't know if he's telling the truth or
if it's real,
but if it is real,
what he said,
that conspiracy show is fucking terrifying.
Did Donald Rumsfeld had a press conference the day before the nine 11 attacks
where they said that some insane amount of money in the trillions was missing
and they couldn't account for it and they were working on it.
And then the next day the Pentagon gets hit in the exact same spot where the
counting offices are.
All that information was stored.
That's what got hit in the Pentagon and they're talking about trillions of
dollars that were unaccounted for.
I see.
I have no understanding of that.
And when,
you know,
it's so abstract to me,
first of all,
when you start talking about trillions of dollars,
I mean,
I don't even,
I can't even wrap my head around.
I don't even know what that means.
And then,
you know,
when you,
you,
you tell me that the money was unaccounted for,
you know,
and they smashed this,
uh,
you know,
playing into the exact or missile.
If you listen to some people into the exact offices,
like what does that mean?
Now they didn't have a backup somewhere.
They didn't back their shit up online,
all that money.
I don't know what happened to that money.
So if you don't know what that happened,
that money,
then this conversation's over because we can't talk until we have any
information.
But there's so many different things about nine 11 that make you go,
why did that happen?
Why did this happen?
What,
what the fuck happened in that tower?
Seven.
You can't say one way or the other.
You can't say that they did do it.
You know that the United States government was involved and he can't say they
weren't involved.
You got to look at it and go,
what,
what did happen?
You would,
you would have to go back in time and watch it all trans.
You would watch.
It would have to watch every single aspect of it play out in front of your own
eyes to really be truly sure.
I believe in some conspiracy.
I like believe that the flight in hundred conspiracy,
that terrorists,
he got shot by a missile missile and then Clinton just pimped it and was like
glue out in the blue up in the middle of the fucking ocean and Clinton's like,
no,
that was a wiring thing.
Yeah.
Fuck you and all your tries it.
I believe if there was a way to avoid telling people that are terrorist attack
at blog that you can affect us.
Yeah,
they do in a heartbeat.
Yeah.
For sure.
They would do,
would hide that information that would say,
well there's an engine malfunction and that's it.
You know,
there's,
if they could find a way to avoid any,
any sort of information getting out like that,
because first of all,
people are going to freak out about something that most likely with 300 million
people in this country,
most likely is not going to affect you.
It's an isolated incidents.
And by the way,
we're immune to those isolated incidents,
but they happen every fucking day all over the world.
And these places where we're supposed to be liberating,
you know,
I mean in Iraq,
fucking buildings just get hit by missiles.
Woopsies you didn't we,
we didn't mean shoot this building,
but we did,
you know,
sorry everyone who died,
I mean that shit is commonplace all outside of the world.
But if the United States government can keep us from recognizing that and just
they would do it,
I don't think they would do it,
do it,
do it.
And they would think they were doing us a favor.
No.
What?
STANDUPS US stand up.
Stand up like these days it's angry and dark and twisted and you know,
resolved.
And only do I want to,
fuck.
That's what it is.
I want to do a show called,
um,
uh,
comedy intervention.
What do you take a guy like Stan hope and go,
look,
here's what we're gonna do.
Okay,
we're gonna,
we're gonna have like eight comics that he likes.
We're going to go through and we're going to make you a one hour special that
you can sell on DVD.
It's going to be clean and you're going to sell,
make $20 million and then you can do whatever you want and you can have a trust
fund for the rest of your fucking life.
Cause I bet if he spent some time just going through what,
what would be buying Regan's setlist I bet his fucking v like if he had a kid
all this like this.
When you had your kids,
did your,
did your
first,
when you first do you go,
fuck,
I'm noticing a lot of this shit everyone else noticed,
but then
no,
I didn't,
didn't think that.
Um,
I mean there's definitely going to be things that you noticed that other people
have already talked about.
But I just said till this day still,
like when I had a little conversation with my daughter this morning and it's
like I'm on drugs.
You had a conversation with your dog daughter.
Oh my God.
I'm like a
fucking when those commercials,
um,
I had a conversation with my daughter this morning.
I went to the,
um,
the store and I got bagels.
She loves,
she loves locks,
you know,
like salmon.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
we're eating bagels and lox and I'm having this little conversation with her.
She's like,
I love salmon.
It's so yummy,
is a really yummy.
It is.
Okay.
I would like some more and we're having this little conversation.
I'm looking at this incredibly cute little two and a half year old person who's
talking to me that I am just,
I love more than anybody I've ever loved ever.
And I'm having this weird little conversation with her about salmon.
Like,
do you want some more daddy?
I want some more.
I am not quite filled up.
And she starts laughing and she like rubs her tummy.
And then,
you know,
I gave her some oranges or their new shows and she tries to make me laugh and
she,
and it's like,
it's surreal.
It doesn't even seem real.
It's,
I,
I always explain children too.
People don't have children.
I'm like,
it's just like mushrooms.
If you haven't done mushrooms,
you really don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
You can't say,
you know,
that doesn't do any good for you.
And it's just an escape.
Like if you ever done it,
if you've done it and you have that opinion,
then I would like to talk to you about it.
Cause I think it's strange that you would have that opinion if you've actually
done much.
Yes.
It,
same thing with children.
You know,
people say,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
it's just a fucking,
just a bunch of fucking souls and you know,
no big deal,
man,
get over it.
You say that.
But it's love.
It's love in the purest form and most of the time you're dealing with douchebags
in life and it's very difficult to be open and loving all the time and did to
really just put out only positive energy or you feel like people walk over you
experiences with that you had when you were growing up getting bullied.
And I had,
everybody has,
you know,
it's very difficult to like put out love like that.
So it's easy to dismiss it when you have an absolute pure form of for like a
baby that you're raising people who don't have them don't understand.
It's like being a born again Christian sort of,
I guess like the,
and you're almost like,
you almost have this look to your friends,
like don't,
don't worry.
When you get saved,
you'll figure it out.
So
all SORTA,
but it's also a tremendous,
where I just felt like a massive growth and maturity and you know,
and pragmatic way of looking at things just just kicked in flux seven gears
higher,
you know,
I started working harder.
I started,
you know,
being focusing more on certain Chet,
look,
you know,
it's,
it's an evolutionary stage.
I really believe that just like,
you know,
when a healthy bird leave the nest,
that's like,
you know,
you talk to kids that are like 30,
that's still live at home,
they're fucked up.
You know,
there's something wrong with them.
They never really went out and did their own shed and they never really became
adults.
They,
they're stuck in this,
you know,
this a salamander stage where they never quite,
blossomed into the mature animal.
And so,
uh,
when I see that,
you know,
I just,
I think that having children is an,
is another stage like that.
I'm not saying that everyone should have children.
Oh No,
definitely not.
Or that having children is going to definitely evolve your,
that you need to do it to evolve.
I'm not saying that some people end up dropping the kids in the tub.
Fuck yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
There's some crazy assholes out there.
And not only that,
sometimes to get involved with someone who's like really detrimental to you,
but you like to fuck them and all of a sudden you have a baby with that person
and now you have this incredibly chaotic relationship.
But they tried to keep the baby from you to him to manipulate you.
And you know,
things can get really ugly.
But for me at least,
I think having,
having a child kicked my,
my,
just my whole being into another level.
Well,
it was,
I went from being a guy who hung out at the Hollywood improv drinking until the
bar closed to literally the week my daughter was born,
being on the road,
every single fucking weak,
like taken feature sets for no money.
Like just cause I knew that I'd get better and better and my really ambitious
just horrifically.
And now I'm now I'm on the place,
so I think I'm traveling like 50 weeks this year.
Just bring your kids with your wife.
With Uni kid.
Yeah.
I'm gonna take them to,
I'm going to,
uh,
doing a trip to Indianapolis,
Arizona,
and then Cancun.
But it's for the bird,
the conqueror.
So we'll go to like the greatest theme parks.
So I'll take them.
Oh that's great.
And we'll take them,
we'll just spend the day at a theme park and they,
and they are,
have like a,
an escort and they can just go do whatever they want.
So now it's,
it's,
it's turning out,
I think this summer we're going to do it pretty heavily.
What,
has there been any of these rides that were the worst?
Like what's the most craziest one you went to?
Um,
I think the stratosphere really fucked my head up last night,
man.
I was like bad the night before I was throwing up in a bathtub and like call my
wife and told her I was running the desert and was like,
I'm fucking out.
I'm not,
don't,
I'm going to get sued for this production costs.
Cause I'm not going to do it.
But don't tell you where that scared of it.
After food and on a bull or after you've been a tight,
once you've been,
once heights is a different thing then heights,
it shuts your brain down to your fingers.
You're moving so fascinating.
You're like,
as I'm talking about,
I'm getting my ass just started sweating like at second I talk about it cause
you get you,
it knocks your stomach out.
I mean I can't even look at the videos online of people on like those Russian
kids climbing on the tower.
We talked about fucking my asshole starts tank.
Oh my God,
it's so hard to watch.
I told them,
I told the man in my mind,
my wife's like,
just tell the producers you can't do it and just be a man about it.
So I called this Guy Dan Adler that morning and I was like,
and I hadn't slept and had been drinking and it was a bad scene.
I was a wreck.
I was a real fucking like rec.
And I was like,
dude,
I can't do it.
It's not going to happen today.
And he was like,
that's fine.
That's totally cool.
I get that.
But here's the deal.
If you're not going to do it,
I need you to not do it on the edge of the building.
Like I need you to get all the way to that moment.
And then back off and I was like,
and he goes in,
you do not have to do it.
I could,
but I can make a show out of that.
I can't make a show if you just go,
I'm not doing it.
So it was like,
okay.
So I went through the whole thing,
did the training,
got the jumpsuit on,
did all my interviews,
got up to the top,
started doing my reads and my camera man,
this Scott Scott Sands is a hanging off the building,
literally tethered in and hanging off the building where the camera fearless
mother fucker.
This guy fucking loves that shit and he's videotaping my,
he's taping my reads and I'm on the edge and I'm fucking my,
I've pissed my pants a little at this moment.
Like it's just bad.
It's a bad scene.
And Scott starts laughing and I go,
what?
And he's like,
you know,
there's like 400 people at the bottom waiting for you to jump.
And I was like,
and he's like,
there's like 200 behind you right now.
He was,
dude,
it's going to be much easier to jump.
And they did tell 600 people and the mayor,
who's waiting for you with a shot of Tequila that you're not jumping.
So it was the first person did it make know is waiting for you in the shot?
I was.
I was the first person to jump on the ride.
I was loop the first guy to do it.
So I was like shit.
And he was like,
I just jumped man.
It's 16 seconds and then it'll be over 60 seconds so long.
It's a fucking three fall for 16 1716 seconds.
16 seconds.
This is your free fall.
You just don't right now.
And right now you're going right now you're thinking,
well the ride works,
but then you're thinking,
man,
this is really freaking the fuck out.
This is really fucking annoying.
I bought,
I'm like,
and you're looking at a target below.
Oh my God.
Still not even time.
You're about eight stadium stories and right now you're fine.
You're 40 stories away.
You still haven't landed.
Did he,
did he shoot yourself?
Explain the ride to me cause I don't know.
It's,
it's controlled descent.
So you,
they took you in on a seven point harness to an end.
They basically a big fishing reel and so you jump and you fall and that,
that tether,
make sure you don't run into the building or like a,
or like swing out of basically keeps you in one kind of area so you can land on
the target.
But what if it gets windy that it was very windy my day,
as a matter of fact,
they do it by gusts.
So it's gusts of like 45 miles per hour,
right?
So it's a win nominal.
So anytime a wind gust hits 45 miles a hour,
they shut the ride down for 15 minutes and then they wait for the wind gust to
go back down.
And my day they were just peaking.
But they were like,
damn fucking a hundred people waiting to do it and they needed open the ride and
you can,
you can see that they're just like,
ignore it,
ignore it.
So then I'm just a fucking,
and I've got my producer,
Lonnie,
is like in the background with my script going like,
I need you to say I'm here in Las Vegas on the top of this drab.
There's like,
and I'm like,
and I just start going,
fuck you lami.
Fuck you.
You can fuck yourself.
I'm fucking jumping right now.
And she's like,
Birkdale job.
And I'm like,
fuck everyone a fucking jumping.
And now I know they can't use any of acts.
You can't use cursing.
Right?
And so then I'm like,
and then I'm like,
I don't let him calm down.
I'm like,
okay,
seriously,
I'm gonna jump k here.
And they just use that me jumping.
So then we do it.
My land,
I have a religious moment.
I start crying,
I take a shot and I'm just like,
I'm alive.
There's no better feeling in the world than surviving a fucking 110 story.
John 110 stories up to 110 stories is the height of the Sears tower.
Think about standing on the edge of the Sears tower and then I get down.
I do it.
I'm like fuck.
And they're like,
they're like,
can you do it again?
And I was like,
no,
I'm not.
I'm done.
So then like two weeks later they're like,
listen,
we didn't get any of your fucking reads.
I was like,
what?
And I'm like,
we can get in your neat breeds.
We need to send you back to Vegas to like do pickups because there was a lot of
shit cause you were so fucked up that we didn't get.
So I was like,
okay.
So they,
we have to reshoot the episode,
but we're just basically everything about the job,
everything about the jumps,
what they're telling me.
So then we get up to the top,
this is going and they're like,
and my buddy Scott sands goes,
look dude,
I put in for like a fucking hundred and $20,000 Lens.
I'm going to sit a mile from you,
but I'm going to shoot you from a mile.
And if you jump it's going to look sick.
And I was like,
Scott,
I'm not jumping.
And he goes,
I'm just saying,
man,
it's your show.
Do you want it to get picked up for a second season?
It's going to look sick.
So then I was like,
fuck.
So I get up to the top and a no,
I'm not jumping up knowing much,
not jumping,
and they get to the top and I realized standing on the edge,
it's easier to jump into walk away from it.
So I was like,
fuck it.
And I just jumped again.
Had the same religious moment you get done at the bottom.
It's not religious.
It's like a spiritual awakening where you're like,
I'm fucking alive.
My,
I'm to hug my kids.
Like,
oh,
they just called,
they called me two weeks ago and they're like the Navajo Bridge and Arizona,
the woman,
he jump off it and do a bungee jump.
It's like 500 feet.
It's pretty gangster for a bungee jump.
500 feet is really high free fall for 400.
Freefall.
Bungee does style.
So I'm looking for take,
uh,
probably play eight seconds.
And the,
and the,
and the real pimp part is you don't jump for dudes,
lift you up.
Like you're on a boat and they just throw you off.
Oh my God.
So you're fucking,
you feel out of control.
And I'm looking for a celebrity to do it with because I don't want to do it by
myself.
Show get the fuck out of here and straighten your back up right away.
You'd never do that.
No.
Really none of that.
I'm not,
I'm not either,
but like I'm doing,
running into tricking my brain and thinking I'm almost dying.
I get it.
It looks like fun.
I don't need that kind of stress in my life.
I've,
it's all my life's filled with right now.
It's crazy,
man.
That's something that,
that much money like he's like,
well is it helping your gigs though should be helped.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I sold out at five shows in DC this week and like it's,
it's,
but it's,
it's family friendly audiences so you,
you just have to train them to do,
to watch what you watch.
You did it.
Was that something you were saying too?
Yeah,
that's what you're saying.
When you were talking about a comedy intervention,
like getting someone in and taking someone and making them super clean and
realizing there's so much money out there and that,
but if you didn't have to,
I couldn't just clean.
Yeah.
And the guy looked stand hope couldn't do it either.
It wouldn't be fun anymore.
It wouldn't be the same thing.
It would be all of a sudden there's a job that you can do what?
You can make money,
but you're not going to be really doing standup anyway.
You're not gonna be doing what your brain will be thinking the way it normally
thinks when you're on stage.
Or I feel like my brain is just juggling thoughts to me like,
Huh,
Ooh,
this would be good.
It can't do that.
If you're saying no,
can't go there.
Nope.
Can't go here.
No.
Can't say that.
Be careful when you say this.
You don't want to offend any sponsors.
So when you do stand up now,
when you were saying that you get them to like what you like,
you know,
or get them to know what you do.
Uh,
start,
uh,
about my kids.
Like I'll start that mean they're not good.
They're not by any stretch of the means.
Clean jokes.
When jokes about my daughter,
my daughter's in a room,
my youngest was fingering her ass and putting it in the dog's mouth and so and
so
figured they're assholes all the time.
She's like,
she'll be talking to me about like playing on the swings and she's just digging
in her vagina.
Oh,
fingers in her vagina.
So maybe we can go into swing.
What do you think?
Maybe we can do that.
Like maybe you can stop thinking yourself when you talking to your dad.
No,
wait.
But that joke,
when you do you,
when you do something about your children fingering their ass,
takes all the parents that went to see a clean show and put everyone at the same
level.
I said,
it does happen.
It does.
So then once their brains get reset for that,
then they go,
okay,
all this shit does happen.
And he's not being mean.
I stopped doing racial jokes,
like being heavy on racial jokes just cause I was like,
I don't fucking know.
I don't care.
Like I don't give a shit enough about equality to put my job on the line to try
to make everyone even like I'll,
I'll get into nights if it's an all black room.
I just do black jokes but not mean,
but just what I do black jokes.
But um,
and then you do that.
Once you do that you have a fucking power of attorney to do anything.
Cause even the clean people go my kid's finger the rest to right rail and then,
and then,
and then [inaudible] I've talked to the audience,
well when you were saying that you um,
you used to do a re,
uh,
racist jokes or racial jokes,
racial jokes,
you know,
w you and you stopped doing them because they offended too many people.
I never gotten,
no one ever got offended,
but I just noticed that I was up for one.
I was obsessing on it.
I can,
I would write,
I could write all day long.
I can write jokes about black people.
I mean if you've sent me,
I swear to God,
if you put me in a room with a black audience,
all I'll do is talk about black people all I'll do.
And like now the dirty,
the one,
only the furthest I go is I have a joke about,
um,
just uh,
I go,
I think is racist that they don't make black baby powder.
Like I just think that from a company named Johnson and Johnson,
they would have thought of that by now.
And then they go,
you know that,
uh,
that's home and make $1 million.
I'm going to buy baby powder.
And then,
uh,
and then,
and then I'll call it magic Johnson and Johnson's.
So then one night there's one,
this is great.
One night black dude's since I'm in an audience in Miami,
goes,
hey motherfucker,
when you get done,
you put the joke about black baby powder.
I'll tell you why don't make shit.
And so I was like,
I'm thinking,
I'm done with a joke now.
Like,
what's,
why don't they make it?
And he goes,
we don't have a problem with moisture the way you guys do.
He goes,
every time I hung a white guys like hugging a dolphin,
he goes black,
you have a problem retaining moisture.
So they have a problem getting ashy.
So they have to always stay moist,
whereas white people are constantly fucking moist.
Wow.
And so he's like,
they just never needed black baby powder black people.
And I was like,
but it was awesome.
It was like a great moment.
I love,
dude,
if I could,
if I had a videotape of every experience that I will buy them,
one of audience,
I would be aid the most famous comic in the world.
The,
I've had black dudes get on stage in Miami,
right?
Real Shit.
Fucking three gangsters in the front row.
True Story.
All my children fucking,
they're ruining the show for everyone.
And I go up and I just talked to them.
One do gets up on stage,
half of day,
my set,
and he's like,
there's,
there's a real mother fucker.
He's keeping it real,
real talk right now.
Real talk,
you know,
real motherfuckers getting the three Oh five and he drops his pants and shows
his Dick Place goes bananas.
Right.
They're like,
whoa.
And it's a the biggest blackest.
It's almost purple.
It's so black like,
but as Jack,
huge,
it's huge.
And I'm like,
that isn't real.
That is bugging real.
And then I'm bugging months,
nine inches.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's a shower.
It's like a thick,
thick,
an uncircumcised.
I'm just looking at it like,
Holy Shit.
So then I go,
I go,
man,
that's fucking,
his name was ray.
I don't know why I remember that.
But I'm like,
Ray,
I go,
I think you might want to get off stage because I can guarantee you you're,
they're calling the cops right now and I don't want you to go to jail for just
showing your deck.
He's like,
I appreciate that.
Good looking out.
And then he puts his pants on and leave.
So then I go,
man,
how do you follow that?
Another gang banger stands up,
gets onstage.
I go,
please tell me.
We're seeing another cock right now.
Pulls his pants down,
bugging just as big but lighter,
lighter,
like a lighter brown.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I'm like,
and I was like,
you might want to go catch up with the breaks.
I can't guarantee you they're calling the cops now.
So they're sitting with,
I swear to all my children,
they're sitting with an heroin,
a hairless albino.
Okay.
And I said,
and now and now that the crowd is like fucking in a fevered pitch.
I go,
that's funny.
Out of all the Dicks,
I wanted to see what was yours.
He stands up,
get on stage,
takes his dick out and it looks like a light house.
There's no grass,
right white.
And they're flipping over fucking tables now.
Like fucking going nuts.
And I was like,
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's my show.
I literally followed that.
You can't follow that,
can't follow it.
I literally,
and I've white glow in the dark Casper that goes dick all was,
it was beautiful and it was good.
It was big.
I swear he was big.
And I was like,
oh,
I was like fucking.
And then,
and then they all waited for me out at the bar and they were like,
dude,
we're taking you out.
And I was like,
I don't know,
this doesn't end this way.
But I was hitting my like,
I want to be David's hell phase hardcore.
And I was like,
I'm fucking going out with these guys.
This is what comedy is about is having this experience.
I went in one time to do radio.
Miami's my crazy club.
Like I go in and I do the fucking morning pimp shell and they happen to have,
if you do the Improv in Miami all the time,
I stopped going to that place,
man,
you can't.
You can't because you're not,
you're famous.
So when they,
how's that gone away?
Before I was famous.
But that club wants to get the best of you.
Like they want to show you you're wrong.
Now what happened with me was I was on stage once then that brought up a boxer,
I forget the boxer's name was,
I think it was Oscar de la Hoya in one of my jokes.
And you,
oh,
you referenced him broke out in the audience over,
you know,
fuck.
Yup,
finish gender,
kick his ass.
And then dudes were standing up and yelling at each other and like an argument
broke out in the crowd over like what boxer was the best boxer?
Who would fuck you up?
And I didn't.
I just stopped and I said,
I'm never coming back here.
Yeah,
that's just a bad audience.
And that could have happened.
No,
no,
no.
That's very common there.
Miami Improv Day,
they lost control of that place a long time ago.
They stopped too many free tickets.
They give away a ton of free tickets if you're white because they can sell
tickets to black people.
And then,
but so one time I go to the morning pimp shell and they have this gang in there
called the XO pound,
right?
A real gang.
Real gang dude.
Look it up there on gang land.
Okay.
These are all Haitian motherfuckers.
So they're doing this thing,
the song Amaa zone.
That's the song that they're singing in studio.
Now mind you,
I'm just doing radio.
I'm doing press like I'm just there to fuck around.
But I know the one thing I do in these stations,
I bring a bottle of Tequila in and then I get everyone drunk and then I just
take my shirt off and we'd go fucking great.
And you do press,
you always bring into kilos sometimes.
Sometimes I've done it before,
but I think that's more because I'm an alcoholic and not like,
not for,
but like sometimes drunk with you in the morning and you'll sell out the entire
fucking weekend cause all anyone's doing is driving to work.
Wishing they were drinking and then they hear you drinking and all the rules go
out the door and every show that you stay on until fucking 11 like you,
it's the eye.
It's been like a little trick I've done.
Wow.
But what do you feel like take a nap.
Take it home.
Take him down.
I was looking,
I look at you when you,
when,
when you go into a radio,
I seen your radios and you'll come in.
Hi.
It's fun.
I'm like,
how do you function for the rest of the day?
Oh I do,
but high doesn't kick your ass a basketball.
I smoke weed and then I go to the gym.
Like it doesn't,
it doesn't affect name the same way I go.
Like if I'll do like in the morning radio and I'll,
I'll,
I'll smoke some weed for the morning radio.
They're like,
I'll go to the gym afterwards.
I go lift weights or run or I'll do the elliptical machine.
Like it feels good.
I usually,
yeah,
I don't do that.
Drank man.
When I drink,
I'm done.
Then I'm damn done.
Um,
I have a very long history of drinking,
so,
but,
oh,
zero pound.
So these guys are saying it.
So we,
and I'm doing shots kill on there and they're calling me cocaine because I'm
white.
And so then,
uh,
so then I tell them,
I go,
you guys can go onto my show tonight if you want.
And they're like,
oh,
we'll come and we'll come and we'll come around it.
You're crazy.
I'm like,
this will be fun because I just seen these guys on gang land,
right?
So they'd come to the show and like 15 minutes in and they walk on stage like
Matt just deep with the fucking bottle of Tequila and they're like,
we're drinking this onstage right now.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
And Dj last comes up and we all just fucking Dj Dj that we're supposed to know
what the fuck that guy is the biggest DJ in south Florida for Latino's.
Yeah,
but like,
and he'll have like if you,
if you're a white comic and you can get in that room and do well,
you'll sell out for the weekend.
Like you're not sell out,
but you'll doubt not sell out.
You know,
I'm buying in west palm this weekend.
Not this weekend.
Next weekend is you doing porn porn Rossi.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're great.
Yeah,
they're great guy.
Hell fucking,
yeah.
I've done their show many,
many times.
Those guys were really cool.
That's a,
that's a great club.
And you probably know Johnny,
that Guy's management now.
Yeah,
I've been to that club a long time ago.
Back when it was a smaller club dude,
that's your market.
Those guys fucking like those people.
Like when you get done a show,
you know who the big comics aren't,
you know the ones that people don't go see our goodbye.
Who based on what comics go.
So do you know guys?
Like everyone was says,
do you know Rogan?
Everyone always wants to know if you know Dane Cook.
Um,
who do you know who like to hang out with in Hollywood?
Basically the,
and I'm always like,
hey,
they're all great,
they're all great.
But uh,
did you ever talk shit about anybody?
Oh yeah.
What comics she talks shit about.
I can't,
I can't sit and say,
I can't say,
but I mean you could probably guess,
but yeah,
I talk,
I talk shit about it.
I got a standard we got to stop cause there's comics.
I've talked shit about a lot,
a lot.
They just came up to me and they're like,
dude,
I'm a big fan.
I'm like,
oh me too.
Me Too.
Stonewashed feeling in the world.
Like,
you know,
Ari is someone who I initially did not like cause I met him one night and he was
just standoffish but he was just sorry he was,
he wouldn't even stand offish.
Yeah.
And I wanted to meet him and then he did it and then he walked away and then I
was like,
I was like,
Oh fuck that guy.
And then I saw and then I saw his amazing racist and I was like,
I saw a clip and I was wanting to hate it.
I wanted to hate it cause yeah.
Yeah.
Then I watched it.
It was the best thing.
I said I don't give a fuck when I see that guy again,
I'm going to make friends with them.
And I saw him at the Improv one night,
like right after the shit went down with you and Mitzia like you guys switched
and I was like,
dude,
I just want to tell you like I'm a big fan.
Like you make me laugh a lot.
And then an orange just like,
really thanks man.
We hung out and then,
yeah,
but if you tell people you like them,
then they like you to a lot of tools you have to fucking do a lot of times.
Yeah,
a lot of times comics or standoffish with each other because everyone is so
competitive and especially early on comics for some reason have this weird thing
where they think that if someone else is being successful that somehow or
another it keeps them from being successful.
Their success takes away from you.
Like that could have been yours or something crazy.
It's like this weird illogical connection that a lot of comics make an a tap.
It almost happens with every fucking comic you meet.
Yeah.
Why is that?
I don't know.
I think I know for cause I'll have arguments with comics in my heads.
I've had argued and fake a fake argument argument with ob from opiate.
Anthony and I had never met the guy in my entire life,
but I love their show and I wanted to get on their show to promote things.
Oh did,
you'd be awesome.
When they're showing they perfect for their show.
They never let me on.
Like they're always like,
no,
they still don't want y'all still and let me on and listen,
opie listens to this show sometimes.
I guarantee you he'll hear about this from Twitter and he'll have you on.
I had a dream on,
cut up some clips of the funniest shit that he said,
and it will be on opiates.
So here's what happened.
I had a dream last night that I could fly and I flew into opiod Auntie's studio
and I was walking around.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Fly through the air.
Yeah,
but there's two out of a plane without planet was flying.
I was flying and it was in a tent.
It was an intent.
And I went in and they had these gift bags and I was like,
oh.
So I opened one up and I was stealing when I was like,
oh,
I want to get one of these.
I love Opie and Anthony is we awesome?
And that was an opiate Anthony scarf.
So I pulled it out and I went,
oh fuck.
I can't use an opiate.
Anthony scarf cause then ever will,
no,
I got it from here and then there'll be like,
we didn't give it to you.
So I put it back and then I left.
I flew away and then I was,
as I was hovering above their tent where they were doing their show,
ob came in and said,
who stole this fucking scarp who's,
and I was like,
you know what,
if I man up to this and tell them,
Norton will have my back.
So I go in and I go in and I'm like,
listen,
I am the one who opened that.
I didn't steal it,
but Norton was in there and it would be like,
who the fuck are you?
You're and he basically,
in my dream,
my brain told me everything about me that I think like all the horrible shit.
So now I'm pissed off at Opi for fucking saying that to me.
So I start getting in a fight with him and then I wake up,
right.
And then I literally laid in bed arguing with ob,
never met him.
I listened to his show every day.
I'm the biggest fucking fan.
So you would like,
you were like preparing yourself and Katie in case I go in and he literally does
the,
you know,
typical ob throw a chess set at me,
like fucks with me,
ruins me,
like tries to make me look like a fool.
He doesn't really do that to comic style.
I don't really does that.
And he did a,
he used to,
I think they used to a lot.
Really?
We,
they did it to the guy that killed himself.
Who?
One of the guy in the bathtub that,
oh,
Richard.
Jenny.
They really did it.
Richard.
Jenny.
Yeah.
They made him like stand outside the studio and they wouldn't let him in what co
all radio show guys would sell out their mom for a bit.
Wow.
Like if they think they can get a good bid out of humiliating me.
What happened with the Richard Jeni thing?
What,
what,
what was the story?
I'm literally,
I've probably listened to every opening,
Anthony,
it's just back in the day they made him sit outside,
um,
sit outside of the studio in the glass and they would,
they made him do his interview from there.
What?
Like,
I think,
I think he was in on it though.
Maybe that went oh,
no,
no.
I don't think they liked him.
Why?
I don't know.
I don't remember this,
the whole story.
I'm probably paraphrasing in a way that makes it horrible.
But yeah,
it was a guy that had a weird reputation.
Now Jenny was,
it was a troubled guy,
brilliant comedian though,
man.
I went to see him when I was an open miker at catch a rising star in New York
and he really influenced me a lot early in my career to the point where I caught
myself a couple of times on stage when I was really young,
when I was sounding just like him,
where I was like,
Ooh,
I got to fucking make sure I don't,
I mean,
I'm selling,
I'm ripping him off.
Like I'm like,
I'm imitating him,
you know?
I think so many comics do that.
Oh well he was so good man.
What anyway,
I saw when I saw him at catch a rising star,
he influenced me so much cause he just free bald.
He had so much material.
He just went all over the place that I'd never seen anybody do that before.
Everybody else that I had seen do sets,
they always had like a sort of a,
an opening.
The dude always do and then have a middle part and then they would have a
closer.
When I saw Richard Jeni,
man,
I saw him a couple times in a row and every time I saw him he was doing like a
different hour and a half.
And I was,
I was like super humbled.
He was so quick.
The,
I remember hosting form of Hollywood improv and I'm in the back watching him and
you know,
I'd come from New York.
So I was like,
in my head I was like,
if I didn't know you in New York,
you're not anything.
Basically it was basically saying,
if you're not Geraldo,
hell uh,
Hedberg in my head.
Right.
So someone says,
he said something and now we're going to go over there and look for,
this is right after nine 11 now they want to tell us to go over there and look
for weapons of mass destruction.
What a load of bullshit is that you think they got them in?
Some lady goes,
they have nuclear weapons and he goes,
listen,
you dumb whore.
If they had them they would have fucking use them.
Do you think they're holding back and I was just on the floor.
I was like,
what a great perception.
Like would they hope?
Would they use them?
Then of course it would have used them be a,
he was,
he was great.
He was so prolific and he was the best guy than I had ever seen at really like
dragging the most out of a subject.
Like he would get on a subject and he would fuck that subject up from all
different angles and right when you thought he was done,
he would go deeper and then he would go deeper and a you would.
It made me realize like,
man,
that's something that's really a present in amateurish comics where they will
touch on a subject and then immediately have a quick joke and then immediately
go to another subject.
To me,
well it's,
everybody in the beginning is me.
I've gotten so fucking lazy.
It's a bad thing,
man.
You know,
it's,
you know,
it's really easy to do,
especially when you get comfortable on stage,
especially if you do a lot of ad libbing.
And yet when you get a good ad Lib,
you're like,
well,
it was genius and keep that as opposed to looking for the better one.
But Jenny,
Jenny would take like any subject,
whatever it was,
and just find all sorts of angles with it.
He never really got the credit,
I think he deserved.
It was really weird,
you know?
I just think people didn't appreciate how good he was.
No.
What was your from the east side Comedy Club in New York and Long Island.
I saw him there too.
And uh,
I remember Peter Bailes,
who was the host,
was just shaking his head back and forth.
He's like,
he did three different hours.
He did three different shows and three totally different hours because he didn't
read it.
Repeat one joke once.
I was influenced by a tell a massively like in New York I'll drinking too that
that oh no,
I was editing thing.
Oh I was fine.
I told you I came in,
explained that because this is a crazy story.
You didn't say this on the podcast.
I have.
I went,
I was in 1997.
Rollingstone magazine wrote a six page article about me calling me the number
one party animal in the country.
It's actually gets a little weirder when you doing stand up back then and just
partying.
Just,
I had a room,
notorious reputation of Florida state for being like funny but being a wild
party animal.
Like what kind of Shit where you doing?
Just Fun Shit like uh,
like fun.
I think Wa loudest guy in the room.
Shit.
You know like I remember I
used to climb up on his telephone pole outside the bars on Tennessee street.
There'll be 500 people out there and I just stand up my go.
Everyone shut the fuck up and listen,
if you want a smoke weed,
go to my house and the cops are all sitting there.
I have tons of weed,
enough for everybody and we're all gonna have a blast and get eye.
If you know where I live,
you're invited.
If you don't ask someone,
just no one tell the fucking gobs and you'd have literally 500 people just
giggling at the idea that someone was offering them weed in front of the cops
face.
And what are the cops say when you did this?
They would laugh too.
Like one time for an election,
uh,
gotten naked for this election and just shit on a pizza box and won the election
election.
For what?
For my fraternity.
I just got up naked and shit on a pizza box and then everyone and then I won.
Did you wipe?
No,
just shit.
I just,
Shit.
I learned one very important lesson when you go number two,
you also go one because I pissed all over the feet on everyone that was sitting
here.
Stop it when you go one.
And so I won the election.
So I'm like all these stories came out.
And then rolling stones like let's do a fucking,
let's do an article on him.
Oh my God.
It gets crazier.
Ready?
Sorry for the you already for the part that you go that you go bullshit.
I will never say bull shit.
I've heard enough of your stories.
I'm not so,
so uh,
so Oliver stone option the rights to my life and then from the article.
So then I try stand up and I moved to New York to just start doing stamps.
I did it once and to in a townhouse,
you know we went amazing.
I can offer my own morning show in Tallahassee.
Really?
Yeah.
Oliver Stone Officer.
The rights of my life.
Like I start doing standup five months later will Smith sees me to stand up and
I got to deal development deal with him like right out the gate.
It's like bill burst style like been doing standup for no time at all.
Development deal based on the article and that the fact that I could competently
do stand up somewhat and then the development deal falls apart with Oliver
Stone.
All the guys that have submitted their scripts for Oliver Stone's movie about my
life,
then get their intellectual property back.
One of the guy takes his movie changes,
my name sells it,
the National Lampoon and it becomes a movie Van Wilder.
So theoretically,
and I say this theoretically loosely,
I'll never be able to sue.
I'm never would sue,
I never would sue.
But I went into national lampoon and did,
do you remember Kevin Couch?
He used to have a show on nationally XM radio.
And I told him,
I said,
bring some exact same,
I've always wanted to find out if this is true.
So then he brought some exact sent and I start telling the stories.
It's like,
I am you one of the guys fucking locks up.
Like hold on,
stop right now.
What do you want?
What's going on here is just like an ambush.
And I was like,
no,
I just want to be able to tell it on radio.
And no,
I'm not lying.
That's all I care about.
All I care about is the story being like true.
Right.
And,
and he was like,
what do you want?
Like your own radio show.
I'm like,
Ugh,
fine.
And then he's like,
we'll do a show putting with the original Dan while and are you happy?
And I was like,
yeah.
And so then he was like pretty much I was like so I can say true but yeah,
you were going to sue them.
They were worried I was going to sue them cause we could,
this mean you have a case,
why don't you just go fucking sue those cons.
Barry Katz
said to me,
one,
they pamper,
you can be one of two guys.
You can be the guy that's Susan doesn't work or you can be the guy that doesn't
sue and works,
which won an Aria.
And I was like,
I'm the one to tell me to do.
I would immediately do the exact opposite.
Very cats,
very catches the guy can't see you said drive a Ferrari.
Why owed everyone money?
He looked like the grimace when they'd sell a toy grimace.
And a car.
Just a big head sticking out of a tiny car.
He's so crazy.
He was,
uh,
he was like a big brother to me.
He was my manager for a long time.
What happened?
You got rid of them,
you wised up,
right?
Yeah.
And just do it was like,
he just wouldn't,
he's never could get in touch with them,
you know?
So I just went to 11 and comment.
I want to Rewatch van wilder,
but it's pretty good.
I've never seen while this is what you do,
Bro,
you find out what the fuck.
And Statute of limitations is,
get to a point where you're so talented.
You're so funny.
You cannot lose.
You just have to keep doing what you're doing.
You cannot lose your very,
very entertaining dude.
They can't stop you.
So once you get to a certain point and then you go after them,
cause a certain point where you're in,
embedded into the zeitgeists as you're just looking for a reason,
I use the words,
I can
show you my range or some man.
What is it?
It's a strange conspiracy movie that they've got three episodes.
And what's actually the cultural,
the idea of being on the mind of the culture.
Get into the consciousness of the culture.
The site case is like the mind frame.
Like how,
what were where people's heads are at right now?
The zeitgeists there was a new one that they just did recently.
I guess it's not,
but it's a lot of,
it's like nine 11 shit.
I tried to watch the first one,
correct shit about certain things about religion and I was like,
and then you get Zike guys debunked and things get really cloudy and people go
online and debunk it.
And who's right,
who's wrong?
I don't have time for this shit.
Yeah.
You know,
but you should sue the fuck out of those van white punks.
I'll never,
I'll never sue them,
but I pretend I'm,
you know,
so for you do it and then just give me your email address bro.
It's one of my pool anytime,
Bro.
Come on.
Bring your daughters.
My daughters in a hard little little park out here.
My daughters will think they swim in there like I can swim daddy.
And I love just that first second where they jumped in and in sync and then you
saved their lives and you see rescue in their eyes.
I can't swim Daddy.
Um,
I'm not into that.
I'm into showing them how to swim.
I'm trying to teach them how to
throw them in like my uncle Johnny,
like,
go for it.
This I learned,
boy,
I don't know how I learned how to swim.
That's how they did it to us.
They just do us in fucking pools.
I can't remember not knowing how to swim.
I just always knew how to swim.
I went to swimming lessons.
I'm must relate.
So I just got thrown in the pool by my uncle Johnny fucking uncle Johnny.
Same Dude whose son fell down a flight of stairs.
Really?
Same uncle and northeast baby.
That's how they did it.
Irish Catholic though.
You in a fucking pool that aren't had a swim.
Yeah.
I grew up native American style in Jersey and and in Boston.
My formative years that that northeast sort
of a mentality.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a lot to that that makes,
makes people like more go getter,
you know,
and it makes people more ambitious.
It makes people more the kind of people that can button down and get shit done.
You know,
there's something about California,
there's something about this weather where it's 85 degrees and in January,
so this makes you weak,
just makes you a soft little bitch.
You know,
I wrote this on my Twitter and I really believe this.
People need visible nature to keep them humble.
You need to see that snow storm common where you know you can't do shit.
Sit the fuck down.
I hope you have a logs to burn because you might need and the power might be out
for a week.
Yeah,
no one's going anywhere and that quiet.
You don't even know what quiet is until you get outside in the middle of a
blizzard when the blizzards over and everything's covered in snow,
like three feet of snow in Boston,
I would go outside and you could hear like,
I like the quiet has like a sound to it.
It's like it's empty.
It's like you don't hear anything.
The snow absorbs it all and it's almost like a fake world.
Like you go walking around and everything is white.
It's like,
I really feel sorry for kids that don't grow up with some snow.
Don't,
don't get to experience that.
And those fucking school days when you,
when you get a day off and he'd go outside and everything's covered in snow and
our grove was note all,
the only problem with that is you could die out there and fucking freeze to
death,
fall asleep in a snowdrift and lose your foot.
Did you hear about this lady in Toronto that happened last week?
The coldest night of the year.
She apparently she had dementia and she froze to death outside of the
neighborhood once she was screaming for people to help her.
Shit.
Yeah,
everyone's screaming.
She just died out there and she was apparently she was at just a known nut.
So like we are,
they're crazy.
That's why it all in the snow.
Yeah.
The Bata dues fall asleep to lose losing for,
I use a foot,
everyone loses it fucking foot.
Sidis still thrown down like
core,
like he still partying at like you were or
down a little?
I don't know.
I've had a major stretch where I didn't drink at all.
Did you feel different on stage when you're sober?
Oh,
I don't drink on stage.
Here's the thing.
Let me just rephrase that cause everyone that's listening has seen me on stage.
He's like,
hold on.
You fell off a stage one night.
The uh,
like I'm falling off stage twice.
The alien hammered,
uh,
Kinda not really.
Like I wasn't that drunk.
He just was bad footing like once in Tampa Improv and once in DC Improv.
But um,
but yeah,
here's the thing is I go up,
I drew,
I will have a beer when I get on stage.
I'll drink it fairly fast,
probably a to sell drinks throughout my show and then I price it.
And then people send you that on purpose.
Yeah.
Really.
Like David [inaudible],
David [inaudible] said to me one night in Miami and probably said,
I was featuring forum.
He said two things when you're featuring,
you should write all the time.
You should never go up and try to kill.
You should be writing and writing because no one gives a shit about you.
And then the second thing he said is when you do get headlining,
remember you are there to sell drinks like as much as you want to do your art,
the more drinks you sell,
the more appetizing you are to the club and the club will bring you back.
If your bar sales are high,
doesn't matter what your ticket prices are.
Whoa.
So I literally just went on stage and I remember an intel would be like,
he bring up,
he wouldn't even bring a drink.
Most of the times you bring up like a,
he'd have them send you.
I mean,
what are I want to get behind that tells theories on drinking on stage or what?
But I would just go up and drink a beer.
So let's say we could figure what you mean complete what you were saying.
He would bring up shots.
I don't know.
No,
he doesn't drink.
So I guess you can say it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's pretty open about it.
He wouldn't drink shots.
He would drink.
It would be like coffee.
Yeah.
Oh,
he would fake it.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
But you didn't drink now.
So I don't think he gives a shit.
But he was telling me,
he's like,
you gotta be sub menu,
it'd be working up there.
Like that was to tell it tell it was never a fucking drunk on stage.
So,
but I would go up and I still do it.
I mean I can bring a lot of beers.
I can go up now and I'll usually what I'll do is I'll play a song that's
inspiring me.
Like,
cause I,
you know,
you get bored doing a lot of roadwork.
One was his song alcohol pussy and we'd buy the Mga Mjb Dna Pol just fucking
great.
Just first 30 cents a song,
alcohol,
pussy in weed,
Pussy.
And we did that.
Got you fired up for a shuttle.
And it would just,
and it was also because I was having family friendly people come out and it
would set the stage.
So then the,
um,
the second song I do with this song by maximum Ludwig and the Santa Fe seven,
it was really great song.
And then now I go out and listen to black Betty by Ram jam.
And then as the song plays,
I'll maybe fucking throw off his shirt,
pound a beer.
Whoa,
Bam,
Bam.
And right now everyone in the crowds fucking love.
And I'm like,
everyone raise a beer.
We're pattern would be right now.
And then the whole fucking room was a beer.
We pound it.
And then right there you've just increased the entire barbs staff.
But the bar bill for the club,
I will five.
How many dudes are going to slide in the trees on the way home though?
My cousin fell down a flight of stairs.
He was at that show.
Oh,
that was the one,
cause then everyone sends shots and like we're talking like,
like aggressive as the most shots you ever drank on stage.
Oh,
I couldn't even guess.
I couldn't even,
maybe like,
I dunno,
take guess more than 10 Oh yeah,
I'm more than 15 no,
no,
no.
Probably around 10 or 12 I've had a lot of shots on stage before,
but uh,
and those shows don't,
those shoes are usually more chaotic.
Like I'd want to tamper recently.
This was like a really great moment where you're just so drunk you can't
function.
So I bring,
I bring a black guy on stage and I do an interview,
great new clothes.
I bring a book,
it's the best,
it's the best.
You bring a black guy on stage and then one of two things will happen.
Either you say something totally hilarious or all the white people just applaud
for what area he says,
right?
He's an engineer.
Yay.
Good for him.
That's what happens.
So I've been this buck on stage and I'm like,
and I,
I tried to guess what job he did and then I used to have a great one where I
bring a black Guy Latino on stage and I go,
let's,
I'm going to see it.
The way I see it.
You say it the way you say it and then I go,
I would like to take you on a date.
And then the Latino guy will be like,
mummy,
mummy.
And then,
and then the black guy will be like,
[inaudible] get some commissary.
Shit,
we do like a bunch.
And the crowd loved it cause they were like,
oh that's right.
The white guys nerdy.
And then had always close with,
all right,
how about this one?
I'd like to apply for a home loan and I give it to the black guy.
And he's like,
oh,
it was great.
It was great.
So I bring this blackout stage in Tampa and um,
I said to him,
I go,
I don't,
I'm at a loss.
We're having a great moment.
Taught,
making jokes,
any.
Then you can slide whatever jokes you do have in your pocket into that moment.
Looks Improv place fucking flips out.
Like I tell him,
Oh,
you remind me and my black friend and he's like,
oh,
you got a black friend?
I'm like,
yeah,
his name's imaginary.
And so then just Bam,
right off the gates.
So then,
so then I tell her the bike,
I go,
what do you want to do?
And he goes,
let's sing a song.
I go,
really?
He's like,
yeah.
I go,
okay.
what song do you want to sing?
And he goes,
journey's don't stop believing.
I was like,
all right.
I go,
do you have that in the Dj booth?
So they start playing it right.
And so now it's me and the black guy singing,
don't stop believing back and forth.
Just a small town girl and he knows all the words and it's killing.
Then I held him,
I got the music and the whole crowd starts singing and it's like,
just this like living in a lonely world.
She,
and you can literally,
we would cut the music and then we'll have it turned back on and everyone's
right on time.
And then at the end of the show it's me in the black,
I know music and the crowd's still singing and it's like do it soft and then you
get your 350 people go just to smell like dog stop.
He then,
and then I'm like,
dude,
isn't it in a Mexican accent?
And then the whole crowd's stop.
But Lehman and then the black guys doing it one more time.
Shirts,
his shirts off,
right.
And then the whole crowd sings.
I grabbed his leather jacket,
throw it on his shoulders.
I'm like,
we're done.
And the you just that moment you can never recreate that.
You can't recapture it.
You can't try to do it again.
Yeah.
That's live performance.
Just being in that moment and being 10 shots in and going,
I don't fuck it.
Fuck it.
I,
this can't end bad.
But yeah,
those are those moments.
And then,
but here's the problem.
Then you get addicted to those moments and then you sometimes like,
okay,
I've got,
there's like 90 year old woman off stage and we were dancing to alcohol,
Pussy and weed and I've got her pinned like donkey style,
like my hands on the ground.
My legs are up over her shoulders and she's just going like this.
And then you get addicted to that and you want to create that and you'd stopped
doing stand up.
She was doing that to you.
It's online.
Just play bigger.
Her,
her,
she was here to see you and your legs were over her shoulders.
It's really hard to explain.
Okay,
I'll see it.
I'll look for it.
But it's just I've been,
uh,
I want to hear more though.
Just tell me more.
Um,
yeah,
so then,
but you get addicted to those moments,
right?
Cause then,
then like what happens is like you have the story that may be a comic,
tells another comic.
When Bert was in Miami,
this m three gangbangers showed their Dick and then other comments,
you're like,
dude,
I can't wait to work with you.
I want to see work because I hear what you do.
And you're like,
and you're like,
I don't do that all the time.
But like it feels,
then you feel pressure and then you go to a set at the Hollywood improv and it's
just fucking eight minutes of material and you're like,
that was uninspiring.
I mean,
don't get me wrong.
You have those moments where like,
like those Oh shit moments where you just like,
this will never fucking happen like this.
Yeah.
Right.
And those are moments too when you're doing like an hour on stage and they get
to know you and you're really in the groove with the crowd on a lot already
best.
Like,
this is an,
I give this to any comic listening if you ever need to do this.
Cause sometimes you get,
you get that reputation and then they go,
you go to a club and they're like,
listen,
we've got a marriage we want,
they want to propose on stage.
We told them it was cool with you.
Listen,
it's a shit dick moment,
but here's what you do.
I've given this to every comic that wants to use it.
It's brilliant.
It count came in the moment I was had like four shots,
Tequila.
I had a guy I want to pose to his check.
This is what you do.
Bring them both up on stage to do a shot of Tequila.
Okay.
The guy knows he's proposing you don't worry about that.
Can almost age.
And then you tell the girl,
we're going to play a game.
We're gonna blindfold you and you're gonna have to feel our chests.
Just start chest and tell which one's your husband and which ones me.
And then she's like,
okay,
so you blindfold her right?
Then you'd tell the dude now and so he gets on his knee with the ring and then
you just release the blindfold.
Dude,
you want to talk about 200 people like crying,
like Oh my God,
the perfect setup.
And it's such an easy way to get out of that.
Like,
cause a lot of times when you're young comic,
the manager just be like,
they're give me 500 bucks just to make sure he proposes to her.
So if you're a comic and you ever get stuck in that situation,
feel free to use it.
It's how I did it and it killed.
There's now what did you do after that though?
Just get all fucking stage.
Someone played back to you.
She made a book called Bert Kreischer Exit Strategy.
Well those are awesome man.
Dude,
thank you very much for coming on the show,
man.
You're fucking hilarious.
He's one of the most fun podcast I've ever had me to know.
And knowing that you enjoyed listening to it and now you're on it and you
probably made one of the best ones we've ever had.
I won't listen to this one,
but I can't wait.
I can't wait.
You can't tell the Tracy Morgan Morgan story.
I'm going to tell him.
Of course.
I just tell the Tracy Morgan and Morgan,
we're going to end on this thanks to the fleshlight.
Uh,
go to,
uh,
Joe rogan.net entering the flashlight.
The thing,
it's like Rogan is the code name and you get 15% off.
I'm in February 4th.
We're at the Mandalay Bay theater.
It's me,
Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir.
That's like a three headliner combo there.
And then next weekend,
not this one coming up,
but next week.
And I'm at the West Palm Beach Improv the 28th,
29th and 30th.
And that is also with young and talented Ari Shaffir.
So tell him what the fuck happened with Tracy Morgan.
Okay,
I'll preface this.
I want to be safe and prefaces that my buddy Jay Moore does tell this on stage.
We have an agreement.
He's my friend.
He's not a thief.
Okay,
that's,
I just want,
I know that Jay is concerned about that,
but he told me he's not telling the story anymore.
And it did happen to me as long.
I mean this is a true story is a true story.
True Story.
So as a young comic working in at the Boston Comedy Club,
we're in the door in New York,
in New York.
Yeah.
And I used to party with all the black comics because they,
well cause I don't do you like to and so we uh,
we used to have a good time and so then um,
one night Tracy Morgan comes in is when he's starting to get back into standup
after SNL.
So like when you were young comic and a new celebrity coming,
you like had to see that shit had to,
so I go in and I watched Tracy set and it is not,
we have nothing in common.
He's doing an observational material and is observational material is like,
all right,
you okay?
Okay.
Who Remembers Vinco fucking bout a handball courts.
And I'm just like,
and he thinks that's a shared experience.
Like losing a sock in the dryer but like everyone else.
And then he walks you through it.
He's like,
you put that bitch up against the wall,
just pussy pop.
That bitch wouldn't even kiss a,
put your arm and your own stank.
And now you have a visualization of like precious getting boxed out at a
handball court,
making eye contact with passer by just getting her buzzy blown out by Tracy
Morgan.
He goes on stage and he's like,
fucking,
yeah,
I hit that man.
I got this new bit about my dick being so pretty out.
You can still go with the lights on,
which is a genius statement.
I never had a blowjob in the light,
but he just didn't word it right.
Right.
So
the lights on.
So he,
um,
so he goes,
he,
uh,
so then he goes,
oh,
you want to get high?
And I was like,
yeah,
and because I'm a grown up and so we walk around the corner and he pulls out
this wreck of a joint hands.
It to me,
hits it and it gives it to me.
I hit it and it tastes like shit.
It tastes like sweat socks.
Like just,
just like,
and I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
And he's like,
oh,
you never smoked a sherm before.
And I was like,
what?
He's like,
show her,
maybe angel does PCB,
you'll never smoked Sharon before.
And I'm like,
you just came to fucking like,
how did you know who ever taught you how to get high?
So I panicked.
Bad,
like hardcore anxiety attack.
I go back to the club,
I'd go to this older black comic who's was instilled as one of my good friends.
And I go,
hey man,
Tracy just gave me PCP.
He's like,
Oh,
oh,
let me tell you something.
Shawty Tracy done smoked PCP.
He's not fees fucking with you.
I was like,
when he's up,
he's got,
he's just smoking pot.
He's fucking with you though.
He's just getting your head.
And I was like,
no,
I smoked PCP.
I'm feeling weird.
And he goes,
whatever you do shoty don't go to your house.
You hang out with us tonight.
So I'm like,
all right.
So I do my set,
I bomb.
We all go out.
And Tracy is in downtown Soho,
like debt,
right on house.
Tim Wright and he's in a club that is like one of those railroad clubs where it
goes all the way back.
You have to like walk down five spice,
a flight of five stairs to get to and he's in the back.
He's been there like 20 minutes and he is holding court with his shirt off.
Okay.
Shirt off,
bottles of champagne covering his table.
There's other tables that have champagne on it.
He's buying it for them.
I buy her a bottle of champagne right now.
I've got a pretty Dick,
like just Eddie Murphy gave me this,
whatever the fuck he's saying is like loud and boisterous.
So I sit at the table and I'm thinking I'm on PCP.
And I started ordering Heineken separately from this wreck of a bar tab he has.
And so I'm getting Heinekens and then the whole night goes through,
it's kind of an interesting,
bizarre experience,
but like two o'clock in the morning and uh,
Tracy and the waitress comes up and she got the bill and she puts it in front of
me because I'm at a table with all black dudes.
So she thinks on their agent or lawyer or coach,
whatever I am.
So she gives me the bill and I see it.
I'm like,
oh,
I can't end.
Tracy Morgan flips out and he goes,
oh,
what the fuck is that?
That's fucking racism.
You give it to him.
He works the Goddamn dog.
He doesn't new,
Ain't,
don't make any money on the rich mobile fucking here I'm on TV.
I'm the ritual,
the fuck.
And he flips the bottle of champagne table upside down.
Now the woman's like uncertain sir.
And he goes,
hey.
And he takes his shirt and throws it in her face,
a bouncer,
it comes up and he's like,
excuse me sir.
And Tracy just wham lays the guy in the biggest fight I've ever been in just
breaks out all over.
People are fighting,
jumping on.
And I think I'm on PCP.
So I walk out on Houseton and I start going,
this isn't happening.
This is the imaginary,
this is not real.
People are flooding out left and right.
And they're like,
dude,
that shit's going off.
Trees has got like four dudes on him.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
A minute later,
the doors kicked open and Tracy Morgan is launched out of the club by the back
of his neck and the seat of his pants just up onto the street shirt on him.
No up on the street,
shirtless laying at my feet on the sidewalk.
Doors close.
Second later door's kicked back open and Tracy's shirt comes out and over end
and lands on his head and it's silent and we're looking at Tracy like,
fuck,
this is crazy.
All of a sudden he looks up,
stands up,
takes a shirt,
snaps it,
and he goes,
now that's how you get out of paying a check.
This guy's crazy.
Like a Fox.
He fucking to walk in with a $6,000 parttime shit getting kicked out of the
park.
But you really did that.
That's all.
That's awesome.
Did he ever have to pay for it?
Whatever.
I have no idea.
I never,
I do.
Here's the thing.
I'll admit.
Only met Tracy wants
you don't hang out with a dude.
More than that.
I would never leave that guy side would have to be.
I
didn't have kids,
I was just,
I was just like,
like Jay used to tell,
I was telling you,
Jay used to tell a story that had happened to me when we do stand up and man
like people would be like,
get outta here.
But like I don't know Tracy and I doubt he remembers the night at all.
Fuck.
And I'm like,
and you know how stories go in your head when you start telling them a lot.
Then you like shorten it and tighten it.
And I've been telling that to comics for like 12 years.
Ever since had happened.
It was a stand up to stand up for like two months.
That's hilarious.
No,
you weren't on PCP.
You just thought you were.
I wouldn't know.
I don't know.
I was,
I was probably strong.
We'd probably strongly,
I dealt with his,
he smoked PCP.
I've heard him on NPR interview saying he's never done drugs.
And I can,
I mean,
I don't know.
I've never done drugs.
He said on NPR piece something that you would probably tell the person,
even if you were at CP user a thing is Tracy,
Tracy's got that.
Like I would say that like prison mentality of like he'd rather fuck with you
then really fuck you up.
Right?
Right.
Like I think you'd rather get in your head then like fuck you.
I don't think he's a mirror and mean spirited person.
He's just playing.
He's just playing with you and then,
and then I'm the one white guy hanging out with all black comics and so then
that's funny that he thinks he's on PCP.
That's great.
But the best.
That's a fucking fantastic story,
dude.
That was one of the funny stories over the next time.
I'll tell you about when I was in the Russian mob and we wrote robbed a train.
Really?
It's a true story,
but I'm not going to tell it now.
Okay,
dude,
you're coming back again soon.
Definitely.
Folks,
if you want to file Burt on Twitter,
it's B.
Follow him please.
One of the fucking funniest guys who've been around show.
Thank you very much,
man.
That was so much fun.
I had a blast.
We will see you bitches on Tuesday.
Halacha boy,
you love.
Yeah.
[inaudible].